Und ich bin ein ganz großer Mensch.
Und ich bin ein ganz großer Mensch. Und ich bin ein ganz großer Mensch. Und ich bin ein ganz großer Mensch. Ich bin schon mal auf dem Weg.
Hallo, ich hab kein Mikrofon.
Also wenn das zum Beispiel... Ich bin schon mal auf dem Weg.
Aber wir klären das jetzt mal, ich mach ganz gut. Ich bin schon wieder da.
Ich bin schon.
Wenn es keine Gravität gä, dann.
Blablabla, da muss ich das hier abnehmen.
Wir sind jetzt wieder an, er Andi. Versuchen wir doch nochmal. Oder soll ich nochmal die Musik, die hübsche Musik machen?
Chaosradio 54. Wir reden heute über das Internet mal wieder, aber diesmal über das ganz große Bild, nämlich wie das eigentlich so zwischen den Netzen, weil das Internet ist ja ein Netz zwischen den Netzen, funktioniert.
Die wunderbare Stimme von Andi Müller-Margun war das. Ich sage nochmal, Janett ist noch da. Deinen Nachnamen habe ich jetzt mal wieder nicht. Das ist Janett. Aber es ist Janett. Janett ist eine der Kandidaten für ICANN, was das ist, was das soll und was das kann. Da kommen wir noch später zu.
Genau.
Dann ist Hauke noch da, was dem qualifiziert. Weiß ich nicht, der hat nicht mehr was zu rauchen mit.
Ich werde jetzt keine Äußerungen dazu abgeben.
Genau und Tim ist auch irgendwo, aber der ist weg. Ist Tim raus?
Er hat es.
Fang nochmal an, Andy.
Entschuldigung, wie soll ich jetzt anfangen?
Du machst doch hier immer...
Dann nimm doch mal diese CD hier und geh mal auf die...
Also das hätten wir nun wirklich sozusagen off-air quasi.
Können wir vielleicht noch ein paar Kommentare zum On-Air-Status vielleicht vergeben?
On-Air-Status.
Genau, weil wir haben ja nun diverse Streaming-Aktivitäten auch wieder gestartet.
Hallo Tim.
Hallo, könnt ihr mich hören? Ich habe irgendwie noch kein Kopfhörer auf. Auf jeden Fall gibt es natürlich den Real-Audio-Stream, der ist auf der Fritz-Homepage vermerkt. Und dann gibt es auch noch mp3-Streams, die von einem Server von uns gehen. Die Uhr habe ich jetzt gerade nicht auswendig. Ich habe die irgendwie rumgepostet. Ihr könnt aber im IRC als IRC-Server IRCCCCDE eintragen und dann in den Kanal Chaosradio wechseln und da wird man euch sicherlich weiterhelfen.
Ja, können wir jetzt mal thematisch werden? Oder soll ich einfach mal Musik wieder... Wer kommt denn der geil?
Ah, komm!
Chaosradio 54. Also 47 hatten wir nix, jetzt haben wir ein bisschen.
47 hatten wir nix.
Ist okay, nee war wieder verkauft.
Du willst jetzt weiter verwirren, ne?
Ja bitte. Worum geht's denn hier?
Wir haben ein Thema.
Das ist gut, ne?
Warum regelt du jetzt gerade die Lautschecke an meinem Kopf?
Weil ich nicht die Lautschecke an meinem Kopf regeln wollte, das tue ich jetzt auch gar nicht. Zugang bitte. Wir haben ja viel geredet in den letzten Jahren über Internet, unter anderem. Und auch darüber, wie das sich so für den Endbenutzer darstellt, das eine und das andere Protokoll. Und heute wollen wir mal so ein bisschen mehr in die Netzstrukturen schauen, die halt die Zentrale ausmachen. Also sozusagen die Backbones und wie eigentlich das ganze Netz zusammenhängt, sowohl technisch als auch administrativ und damit letztlich auch politisch. Es hat da gerade in den letzten Monaten viele interessante Diskussionen in Entwicklung gegeben, insbesondere im Hinblick auf diese Icann-Wahlen.
Jetzt reden wir mal drüber.
Ja erklär mir mal, wie geht ein Internet?
Wie geht ein Internet? Na, hast du schon mal drüber nachgedacht ein Internet-Service Provider werden zu wollen, Holger?
Häufig, ja.
Und ab welchem Zeitpunkt hast du es dann ausgegeben, es werden zu wollen?
Nein, also sagen wir mal so, ich hab mir dann immer mal gesagt, man, wär ich bloß mein eigener Provider, dann wär der ganze Kack nicht. Aber das war's dann auch. Also ich hab mich dann nicht weiter drum gekümmert.
Ja, man hat immer viel Ärger mit den Providern, weil die Provider auch immer viel Ärger haben. Unter anderem mit den anderen Providern, aber auch mit so anderen Organisationen, die da halt noch eine Rolle spielen, mit denen man sich irgendwie halbwegs vertragen muss, wenn man irgendwie was hinbekommen will. Ist denn das esch, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Internet-Service Provider werden will, wie fang ich da an? Also ich meine, jetzt kopie ich mir irgendwie ein paar Geeks, so ein paar langhaarige Sandalenträger, die irgendwie auf irgendeiner Linux-Con rumlaufen und die irgendwie klug da her schwatzen. Dann meine ich, oh cool, jetzt habe ich schon mal mein Personal. Dann habe ich so einen Venture-Kapitalist.
Nee, das ist ja nicht ASP, das ist ja Start-up. Na ja, es gibt auch ASP-Start-ups.
Ja genau, ich habe halt, weißt du, ich liefere einfach die Daten einfach ganz cool, multimidial und dreidimensionale IP-Pakete und so.
Also aber da fehlt doch noch etwas ganz Wesentliches, weil wenn man ASP wird, dann braucht man doch diese Packung Internet, und zwar die große, die rechts unten da.
Na eigentlich braucht man sie nicht gleich die ganz große und ganz unten, sondern man kann auch erst mal klein anfangen und eine Leitung bei einem größeren ASP einkaufen und dann die Packung Internet, die man über diese Leitung bekommt, an seine Kunden weiterverkaufen.
Aber ich brauche doch auch noch dann IP-Nummern, um meine Kunden sozusagen adressieren zu können und damit meine Kunden wiederum rückadressiert werden können und sofort.
Na, die IP-Adressen bekommst du als kleiner ASP zusammen mit deiner Leitung von deinem Uplink.
Und Uplink heißt der größere Provider?
Genau, Kapitalisten.
Und will der Geld für die IP-Nummern oder wie läuft das?
Für die IP-Adressen selbst darf er streng genommen kein Geld haben wollen. Er kann aber natürlich Geld berechnen für den Aufwand, der ihm entsteht, für die Bürokratie, die mit der Vergabe dieser IP-Adressen zusammenhängt.
Und das heißt, dass de facto der wahrscheinlich dann schon mir wie viel ungefähr abnimmt, wenn ich sage, ich will mal so 5000 IP-Nummern haben?
Das funktioniert gar nicht in der Hinsicht, man muss den Bedarf begründen. Wenn ich sagen kann, ich brauche ganz viele Adressen, dann bekomme ich die auch, wenn meine Begründung dafür, dass ich die haben möchte, gut genug ist.
Was wäre denn eine gut genügende Begründung?
Also nicht damit, es ist keine gute Begründung zu sagen, ich werde übermorgen ganz viele Kunden haben. Deshalb habe ich jetzt schon ganz viele IP-Nummern bekommen.
Das könnte auch gehen, wenn man die Illusion, ganz viele Kunden beizuhaben, hinreichend begründen kann.
Ah, das ist wie mit Venture-Kapital, was du gerade sagst.
Die IPv4-Adressen sind ja einfach knapp.
Wie knapp?
Knapp sind sie eigentlich im Moment noch nicht wirklich. Es wurde nur vor ein paar Jahren festgestellt, dass wenn wir mit der Vergabe so weitermachen, wie wir das bisher gemacht haben, nämlich jedem gleich einen großen Karton geben, sie bald sehr knapp werden würden.
Wie viele sind theoretisch möglich? Oder wie viele sind möglich?
Im IPv4 sind die Adressen 32 Bit groß, das heißt es sind 32.
Aber jetzt nehmen wir mal ganz kurz an, ich habe jetzt eine verdammt gute Begründung und der etwas größere Provider, den ich anspreche, der hat aber gar nicht so viele.
Der größere Provider wird im allgemeinen Mitglied bei einer sogenannten Regional Internet Registry sein. Für Europa ist dabei zuständig das RIPE NCC in Amsterdam.
Was heißt das?
Das dort eine...
Nein, was heißt RIPE NCC?
Das ist etwas französisches, das kann ich nicht aussprechen.
Aber es schmeckt gut.
Der Name stammt noch aus dem Forschungsnetz.
Es ist die Vergabestelle für IP-Adressen für eine bestimmte Region. Welche Region?
Das RIPE deckt die Region Europa, Osteuropa, Nahosten und nördlichen Teil von Afrika. Dann gibt es noch zwei weitere sogenannte Regional Internet Registries, nämlich das APNIC für Asia Pacific und das ARIEN für den amerikanischen Nord- und Südkontinent und den südlichen Teil von Afrika. Es gibt aber momentan Bestrebungen, zum Beispiel für Afrika das sogenannte AFRINIC einzurichten, aber das sind bisher noch Versuche.
Und das heißt, irgendwann ist Gott im Himmel hinabgestiegen, hat diese drei Registries gegründet, hat die IP-Nummern gleichmäßig unter Ihnen aufgeteilt und seitdem sitzen die da und verteilen die? Ich meine, wie ist denn das gelaufen?
Wo kommen die her? Also ich meine, es gab ja früher nicht so eine internationale Aufteilung.
Die kommen von der früheren IANA, die hat die vergeben. Also da hat irgendwann mal eine Dezentralisierung stattgefunden und dadurch sind diese drei Vergabestellen, diese regionalen, entstanden.
Und die IANA hat vorher die IP-Nummern bekommen?
Aus dem Protokoll IPv4, da ist halt ein Adressfeld drin, das entspricht einer gewissen Anzahl von Adressen, die er noch nicht genannt hat. Vielleicht tut er das ja noch.
4 Milliarden.
Das heißt aber ja, dass eigentlich so ziemlich jeder erwachsene Erdenbürger eine IP-Adresse bekommen könnte.
Ja, das Problem ist nur, dass immer bei diesen Adressräumen ist die Ausnutzungseffizienz grauenhaft gering. Also da sind es vielleicht bisher 10-20% der verfügbaren IPs...
Also das Problem ist, eine IP-Adresse teilt sich halt in zwei Teile. Nämlich in einen Host-Teil, also das, was sozusagen tatsächlich einen Rechner spezifiziert, innerhalb, und das ist der andere Teil, eines Netzwerkteils. Und dieser Netzwerkteil wird eben vor allem auch zum Routing dieser Informationen benutzt. Es wird sozusagen gespeichert, wo ist dieses Netz angeschlossen, wo muss ich das lang schicken, damit die Daten das auch erreichen. Und dadurch fragmentiert sich diese theoretische Zahl von 4 Milliarden ganz beträchtlich, weil die eben nicht so effizient verteilt werden kann.
Nochmal mit dieser Auslastung. Das heißt, es gibt 4 Milliarden IP-Adressen, sagen wir mal, und davon werden aber nur 500 Millionen benutzt. Und was ist mit dem Rest? Der Rest gehört hier online, für den Fall, dass irgendwann mal mehr User kommen?
Vor allen Dingen amerikanische Einrichtungen, die relativ vorne dran waren, was Zugang zum Internet anbelangt. Die haben sehr große Adressblöcke, und haben die zu einem verschwindenden Anteil überhaupt nur ausgenutzt.
Und der Rest liegt jetzt bei denen rum, und da kann auch kein anderer dran?
Ja, also das ist an sich noch kein Skandal. Das ist im Telefonnummern-System nicht viel anders. Der Skandal besteht allenfalls darin, dass der Ausnutzungsgrad im Internet noch deutlich geringer ist als im Telefonnetz.
Und wird dem Abhilfe geschaffen, oder wird das einfach hingenommen?
Das ist im Moment noch kein konkretes Problem. Die Adressen für den Betrieb des Internets sind da. Die werden auch noch eine absehbare Zeit halten. Es sind momentan, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, ungefähr 60% des verfügbaren Adressraums vergeben. Und von diesen 60% sind wiederum nur 40% in Benutzung. Das heißt, da sind einfach nur mal jede Menge frei. Wenn man jetzt allerdings erstmal den vorhandenen Adressraum vergeben hat, ist vorerst Ende mit der Vergabe. Da müsste man anfangen, von den genannten amerikanischen historischen Institutionen die Adressen mal zurückzufordern. Da wird es aber wohl Probleme geben.
Und die IANA, die gibt es in der Form gar nicht mehr?
Die wird abgelöst jetzt.
Durch? Gibt es die dann noch oder gibt es sie dann nicht mehr? Also ich meine, kannst du mal kurz die Entwicklungsgeschichte grob? Die habe ich nämlich verpasste, IANA.
Also IANA ist die Internet Signed Numbers Authority. Authority ist ein schön wager Begriff. Das könnte sowohl eine Institution als auch eine einzelne Person sein. Bei der IANA war das halt eine Person. John Postel mit Namen. Der war dafür zuständig sowohl RFC-Nummern. Also die Internetstandards heißen ja RFC, Request for Commence. Der hat sowohl diese Standardisierungsnummern vergeben, als auch IP-Adressen zugeteilt. Und das hat der bis vielleicht 1995 relativ unangefochten getan. Und dann haben sich manche Leute begonnen, darüber aufzuregen, dass das nur eine einzelne Person macht und der quasi über die wichtigsten Ressourcen des Internets relativ hemsärmlich verfügen konnte.
Hemsärmlich heißt, er hat sich auch nicht unbedingt drum geschert, was da jetzt mit passiert.
Er war sehr angesehen in der Internetgemeinde.
Muss man schon sagen.
Er gehörte zu den sogenannten Vätern und hat viel geleistet. Und deshalb hat er zumindest unter den Techies der frühen Netzgemeinde ganz große Autorität genossen.
Und wer hat sich dann da aufgeregt?
Der Konflikt, der da entstand, das war der um das Domainnahmensystem. Der John Postel hat damals den Vorschlag gemacht, um 95 rum das Domainnahmensystem ganz erheblich auszuweiten. Damals zeichnete sich so allmählich ab, dass es unter.com voll werden würde. Und da hat John Postel gesagt, dann lasst uns doch einfach 500 neue Top-Level-Domains einrichten. Und da haben verschiedene Leute protestiert.
Warum?
Warum die dagegen protestiert haben?
Also das ist ja letztlich, also ein neuer Top-Level-Domain würde ja bedeuten, dass Adressen in Europa.eu enden würden. So war es verstanden.
Zum Beispiel oder auf dem Shop, Marktpunkt oder so. Aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel den Domainnamen www.business.com hat, ist der unheimlich viel wert. Aber wenn man 500 neue Top-Level-Domains einrichtet, dann ist er vielleicht nicht mehr so viel wert. Weil dann haben 500 andere Leute irgendwas mit Business dort so und so.
Aber kann man dann sagen, wegen geschäftlichen Interessen, und zwar wegen den Leuten, die ja wahnsinnig viel Geld damit verdient haben, diese Namen zu verkaufen, war der Protest, ich meine, das war ja kein Öffentlicher.
Damals kosteten die ja nicht viel. Das ist ja eine öffentliche Ressource gewesen. So haben die Internetingenieure das auch verstanden, dass das ein öffentliches Gut ist, wo der erste, der kommt, den Zugriff auf die attraktiven Namen hat.
Ja, mehr zum Protest nach den Nachrichten.
Na, aber man könnte ja vielleicht schon mal andeuten, vielleicht haben wir diese Sekunde noch, wie die Geschichte weitergeht, weil dann passiert nämlich etwas, was nicht vorhergesehen ist. Der gute Mann hat den Löffel abgegeben.
Ritz, Kurzinfo.
Da ist Wetter, die Temperaturen sinken in der Nacht auf 10 bis 5 Grad, es ist wolkig und gelegentlich regnet, es morgen wechselnd bewölbt kaum Regen bei maximal 19 Grad. Und die Meldung mit Gerald Kötter-Einrich.
Berlin droht morgen ein Verkehrschaos. Tausende Trucker und Taxifahrer aus ganz Deutschland wollen mit einer Sternfahrt gegen die Ökostreuer und die hohen Spritpreise protestieren. Berufspendern wird empfohlen mit der S- oder U-Bahn zu fahren. Heute hatten hunderte Spediteure in Stuttgart eine steuerliche Entlastung gefordert. Nach den Grünen hat auch die Bundestagsfraktion der SPD die Rentenreformpläne von Arbeitsminister Riester gebellicht. Riester kündigte an, er werde noch in dieser Woche Union und FDP zu einer neuen Konsensrunde einladen. Das Ergebnis der Präsidentschaftswahlen in Jugoslawien soll morgen bekannt gegeben werden. Sowohl die Regierung um Präsident Milošević als auch die Opposition um den Kandidaten Kostunica sind von ihrem Sieg überzeugt. Der israelische Ministerpräsident Barak und der palästinensische Präsident Arafat sind am späten Abend zusammengekommen. Beide wollen versuchen, den stockenden Friedensprozess wieder in Gang zu bringen. Das Treffen findet in Baraks Privathaus statt. Ein Charterflugzeug der Turan's Avia Airlines mit 238 Passagieren an Bord musste auf Kreta Not landen. Kurz nach dem Start vom Flughafen der griechischen Insel war ein Triebwerk explodiert und in Brand geraten. Der Pilot konnte die Boeing 757 aber sicher landen. Es wurde niemand verletzt.
Donnerstag 28.
September in den ukamerkischen Bühnen Schwed.
Ich bin schon wieder da. Ich bin schon wieder da. Ich bin schon wieder da. Ich bin schon wieder da. Ich bin schon wieder da. Ich bin schon wieder da. Ich bin schon wieder da. Ich bin schon wieder da. Genau, der hatte gesagt, verteilt die Dinger noch neu, mach 500 mehr und da haben sich Leute drüber beschwert, die damit Geld verdienen wollen, dass es wenige Top-Level-Domains gibt. Und dann ist Postel bestorben.
Ja, aber nicht deshalb.
Also stellen wir mal fest, der Mann hat das irgendwie mehr oder weniger alleine gemacht, kann man behaupten. Und dann hat er eine Vorschaff gemacht, der nicht auf Gegenliebe gestoßen ist. Zumindest nicht überall. Weil es nämlich durch das Namenssystem, das ist ja entstanden, weil irgendwann die Leute gesagt haben, wir können nicht immer nur mit Alpinumann miteinander reden, weil wir sind ja Menschen und nicht nur Computer.
Der Vorschlag, der nicht auf Gegenliebe gestoßen ist, war 500 Top-Level-Domains einzuführen, richtig?
Genau.
Und das sind halt so Illustro-Organisationen wie die OECD, die amerikanische Regierung, die EU, WIPO, WIPO, von der werden wir vielleicht später auch nochmal zurückkommen. WIPO, eine UN-Unterorganisation mit Sitz in der Schweiz. Die haben sich dann jedenfalls alle zu Wort gemeldet und fanden, dass man jetzt die ganze Verwaltung des Internet mal auf neue institutionelle Füße stellen muss. Und das fanden die übrigens bei der IANA auch, dass das Ganze jetzt ein bisschen groß geworden ist und auch relativ viel ökonomisches Gewicht gewonnen hat und dass es jetzt einen institutionellen Rahmen braucht, der auch irgendwie rechtsfähig ist.
Und der Rahmen ist welcher?
Sollen wir jetzt darauf zu sprechen kommen? Wollen wir jetzt schon mit ICANN anfangen?
Warum nicht? Also ich meine, dann können wir schon mal so grob andeuten, aber eigentlich sollten wir noch kurz. Ich meine, das ist jetzt einer der Entwicklung Strenge. Es gibt ja noch ein paar andere. Aber einer der Entwicklung Strenge ist sicherlich, wie ICANN entstanden ist. Und ICANN hat ja viele andere Funktionalitäten, die sich auch so parallel entwickelt hatten, dann letztendlich, ich will nicht sagen, vereinnahmt, aber doch zumindest versucht sich da als Koordinationsbüro.
Im Kern machen die genau das, was die IANA vorher gemacht hat. Die haben die Names und Numbers, die Verwaltung der Names und Nummernressourcen des Internets.
Aber die Produkturentwicklung läuft ja nicht völlig unabhängig von ICANN. Okay, die Entwicklung, aber nicht die Implementierung.
Damit hat ICANN nichts zu tun.
Doch, alles mit den Namen und mit den Nummern zu tun hat. Also, es liegt ja alles nicht so weit auseinander.
Wir sind jetzt im Wesentlichen über die IP-Adressen und die IP-Adressenvergabe dahingekommen. Aber der eigentliche Punkt, über den wir geredet hatten zunächst einmal, war ja, mit was für Organisationen habe ich es zu tun, wenn ich einen Internet-Service-Provider aufmachen möchte? Oder war die Nummerngeschichte halt das eine? Das heißt, ich brauche erstmal andere Provider, mit denen ich mich auseinandersetzen kann, um überhaupt erstmal an Daten heranzukommen. Also, irgendwo muss ich mich andocken, um überhaupt am Internet teilnehmen zu können. Dann kommen letzten Endes diese Nummervergabe-Organisationen mit rein. Das wäre halt in Europa das RIPE. Wie ist denn das bei den Domain-Namen? Also, mit wem muss ich mich denn als brandneuer Internet-Service-Provider starten, mit tollen Firmen, wo viel Geld rausgeschmissen wird? Mit was für Organisationen muss ich mich jetzt auseinandersetzen, wenn ein Kunde kommt mit, ich möchte irgendwie gerne www.deckmich-am-arsch.de irgendwie für meinen Kunden einrichten. Was mache ich dann?
Dann musst du dich zunächst mal mit dem bisherigen Inhaber der Domain auseinandersetzen.
Und ihm diesen Domainnamen abkaufen befürchte ich.
Dann geht das auch nicht, weil Domainnamen nicht mit Ziffern anfangen dürfen.
Ich schreibe es halt aus.
www.deckmich-am-arsch.de gehört übrigens irgendwie zu www.xxx6.com Ja, das ist klar.
Das hätte vor zwei Jahren wahrscheinlich noch funktioniert, aber jetzt muss man sich schon was ausfallen. Aber ich denke, dass es 27 B-6 und voll ausgeschriebene deutschen Worten vielleicht noch nicht... Also nehmen wir an, es gäbe das noch nicht. Was kann ich tun?
Leck mich fett am Arsch, geht noch.
Holger, du wirst schon wieder ausfallen.
Entschuldigung, ich wollte nicht ausfallen werden. Aber leck mich fett am Arsch, geht noch.
Gut, dann müsstest du dich zunächst mal hinschalten.
Hey, ich komme gleich mit dem A-Wort, Holger.
Leute, habt ihr noch was von dem Zeug?
Wie bekomme ich jetzt... Holger!
Also.
Du bist nur ein Fritzen-Moderator.
Ja, eben. Ja, ich guck mal, was ich kann.
Du, sag mal was.
Wir können jetzt mal wieder zum Thema kommen.
Müste man sich zunächst einmal entscheiden, unter welcher Top-Level-Domain man denn seine Lick-Bich-Wert am Arsch die Domain nun anmelden möchte?
Also, und um das nochmal kurz zu erklären, man kann sich da entscheiden zwischen zwei verschiedenen Arten, zwischen den sogenannten Generic-Top-Level-Domains. Das sind sozusagen welche, die einfach so kreiert wurden, ohne dass damit eine bestimmte Organisation eigentlich in direkten Zusammenhang steht. Und dann gibt es noch die Country-TLDs.
Das stimmt doch nicht.
Also von COM, NET, ORG, GOF und MIL, da stecken natürlich schon teilweise. Und EDO.
Und INT.
Da stehen da Organisationen dahinter. Aber gerade geografischen, keine geomunikischen Einheiten.
Das stimmt nicht, weil COM ist ja keine Organisation. Im Moment, Cernet, ich meine, was ich damit aussuchen will, ist doch, wenn man eine Country-Top-Level-Domain hat, da gibt es da ein Staatsgebiet, da gibt es irgendwie eine Regierung, das ist ganz gerade...
Bist du aus Palästina, bist du aus Hongkong?
Ja, okay, aber so vom groben Prinzip her, ja. Ich vereinfache ein klein wenig. Wenn du das in der wissenschaftlichen Präzision hören möchtest, dann wirst du es selber aussprechen müssen. So, und ein COM-Domain ist doch keine Organisation, sondern es ist A, Network Solutions lange gewesen, also die Mafia.
Wer ist Network Solutions?
Okay, also in der Urgeschichte des Internets, da gab es halt diese... Ah, Janett, ich sage jetzt gar nichts mehr, wenn du das nicht erklärst. Ich meine, es ist doch so...
Nein, das ist ja auch nicht so schön.
Also Network Solutions ist ein Laden, der eine Zeitlang quasi monopolistisch, weil es war halt der einzige Laden, der es gemacht hat, die Registratur für die sogenannten Generic-TLDs gemacht hat.
Also generische Top-Level-Domains beschreiben einen Organisationstyp. Country-Code Top-Level-Domains beschreiben eine geografische, schrägstrich, geopolitische Einheit.
Perfekt. Außenstaatliche Präzision zahlt sich aus. Ja, aber das... Was muss ich jetzt als angehender Internet-Service-Provider tun, um entweder eine generische, eine Organisationsform beschreibende Top-Level-Domain oder vielleicht eine geopolitisch oder geo, was war das andere, strategische Top-Level-Domain irgendwie zu erhalten?
Nun gut, nachdem man sich nun für eine Top-Level-Domain für seine LMFA-Domain entschieden hat, muss man nun zunächst überprüfen, wer denn für diese Top-Level-Domain zuständig ist. Für die Top-Level-Domains com.net.org gibt es da inzwischen mehrere Registrars, aber zum Beispiel für DE ist im Moment das sogenannte DE-Nig zuständig.
Deutsches Network Information Center.
Nein, nein, jetzt wollen wir das erst mal zu Ende hören.
Aber die Sache ist doch, die nehmen immer an, du willst dich jetzt an jemanden finden. Und gehst von dem von Jhonnett eben beschriebenen System aus, dass es entweder diese geografischen Dinge gibt, oder eben die Dinge, die von Organisationen gelaufen werden, dann gibt es da Fälle, wo leider das nicht ganz hinhaut. Weil zum Beispiel Tuvalu, was eigentlich was Geografisches ist, hat halt schöne DLD-Kennungen.
Genau, aber richtig fett verscheuert.
Und die haben das jedenfalls verkauft. Und jetzt gibt es also einen Laden, der verkauft ihr jetzt Domains auf der DLD TV.
Ja, aber nicht wirklich erfolgreich.
Das sei mal dahingestellt. Aber was ich damit nur ausdrücken will, ist, dass der Namensraum eben, ja, ist halt im Moment begrenzt. Und zwar dadurch, dass es eine bestimmte Anzahl von Ländern halt gibt. Und zum anderen dadurch, dass ICANN eben die Institution ist, die über diese generischen, ja, ein bisschen bestimmt, inwieweit es jetzt neue gibt oder nicht neue gibt. Oder die eben diesen Namensraum gerade künstlich einengen. Und die künstliche Einengung, das war der Ausgangspunkt unseres Gesprächs.
Der Ausgangspunkt war, was du machst, wenn du Pro-Wire werden willst.
Das ist ja gleich die netzpolitische...
Als Pro-Wire willst du doch TLDs haben.
Andi, ich bin sehr dafür, dass wir auf diese netzpolitische Diskussion gleich kommen. Ich wollte einfach mal kurz den Arbeitsablauf aus Sicht eines Internet-Service-Providers kurz geklärt wissen, damit wir dieses Thema auch abhaken können.
Ich wollte dich darauf hinweisen, dass du im Moment nicht drum herumkommst als Internet-Service-Providers mit der Mafia zusammenarbeitest.
Ich möchte dich nicht darauf hinsetzen, dass du Ash gerade nicht ausreden lässt.
Tim, würdest du bitte mal F-Aussehen lassen, sonst müssen wir dir leider die rote Karte.
Um eine Domain zu beantragen, muss man sich den entsprechenden Zuständigen für die Top-Level-Domain suchen. Sagen wir, wir nehmen lmfa.de. Dann wende ich mich als Demit überprüfen, ob diese Domain noch frei ist. Gehen wir davon aus, sie ist noch frei. Dann trage ich diese Domain auf meinen Nameserver ein, die ich hinter meiner mit kapitalistischen Mitteln erworbenen Leitung stehen habe und sie mit Internets versorge. Dann stelle ich einen Antrag ans DENIG oder an eins der Mitglieder des DENIG, was im Allgemeinen wieder die größeren Provider sind. Wenn dieser Antrag dann den üblichen Registrierungsprozess durchlaufen hat, wird die Domain in den Nameserver des DENIG eingetragen und ist somit weltweit verfügbar.
Eine Nachfrage, du hast jetzt das DENIG eingeführt. Das DENIG ist ja der Betreiber der DE-Registratur. Wer hat denn das DENIG dazu gemacht?
Beziehungsweise, von wem bekommt das DENIG wie die ganzen DEs?
Das DENIG, das man ein DE von ICANN und macht es den Rest sozusagen selbst. Das war vorhin ja schon die Frage, woher eigentlich das RIBE oder ICANN oder wer auch immer die IP-Adressen nehmen, wie erfinden die? Jetzt gibt es da 32 Bildadressen und die kann man benutzen.
Aber das DENIG ist ja auch wiederum eine Rechtsperson. Das sind ja Leute, das ist eine Genossenschaft, richtig. Aber trotzdem sind da ja Leute, könnte man jetzt bösartig behaupten, die verdienen Geld damit, dass sie Domains im DE, der TLD-DE verkaufen. Und jetzt sag mir, wer hat diese Leute und warum heißt das Ding DENIG und nicht Wurzelurz? Also ich meine, warum ist es nicht jemand anders? Wer hat die legitimiert?
Als das DENIG angefangen hat zu existieren, war es, ich glaube noch die...
Das war ein Modellversuch.
Das war die Unidol letztlich.
Genau, an der Karlsruhe. Nein, erst Dortmund, dann zog es um nach Karlsruhe und das DENIG steht ja eigentlich immer noch irgendwie in Karlsruhe. Zumindest der Nameserver.
Also DENIG ist in Frankfurt jetzt, meine ich.
Also das letzte Mal als ich nachgeschaut habe, war irgendwie der autoritative Nameserver für die Ehe noch Karlsruhe. Aber das hat sich glaube ich in der letzten Zeit tatsächlich geändert. Da wurde aus Datenschutzgründen mächtig gewaltig umgebaut und zwischendurch hat es dann nicht so gut funktioniert. Da gab es diese Geschichte mit den Postleitzahlen im ostdeutschen Bereich, die mit einer Null beginnen. Wenn man das als Zahl speichert, funktioniert das mit der Null am Anfang nicht so ganz gut. Umlaute, Telefonnummern und ähnliche Herausforderungen stellten sich. Das ist ja alles sehr neu noch. Gerade das mit den Postleitzahlen.
Ja gut, also das heißt, die kriegen das eingeschränkt hin, ja?
Sie geben sich Mühe. Und meistens funktioniert das auch.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt ein Internet-Service-Provider bin und ich weiß irgendwie, wie ich mir Domains hole und wie ich mir Adressen hole, dann ist das eigentlich alles, was ich tun muss?
Die Kunden wären vielleicht noch drin.
Sonst geht das so ähnlich wie das Internet.
Und zu den Kunden, dazu braucht man nur Venture-Capital, darf ich?
Naja, angenommen, ich habe jetzt viele Kunden, dann habe ich ja irgendwann vielleicht ein kleines Performance-Problem, wenn ich nur über einen einzigen Provider diesen Leuten Internet anbiete. Wie schließe ich mich denn mit anderen Internet-Service-Providern zusammen?
Na, das ist die nächste Stufe des Großerwerdens eines Providers. Man kann dann zunächst anfangen, eine zusätzliche Leitung zu einem zweiten Uplink zu schalten. Oder man kann direkt wieder zu seinen Venture-Kapitalisten gehen und sich die nächste große Tüte Geld holen und eigene Systeme an die strategisch wichtigen Orte dieses Planeten stellen. In Deutschland gibt es davon zwei in Frankfurt und einen in München. Da mietet man dann Platz in einem 19 Zoll-Schrank, stellt einen Router hin und fängt an mit anderen Providern Datenaustauschabkommen auszuhandeln, sogenannte Peerings.
Die kaufen sich Connectivität.
Wenn es ein Peering ist, das auf Gegenseitigkeit basiert, das heißt, es ist ein Provider A, der hat ein Peering mit einem Provider B und die tauschen nur untereinander Daten aus. Das heißt, Kunden von Provider A können auf Server bei Provider B zugreifen und umgekehrt. Dann ist das im Allgemeinen eher kostenfrei, da es ja einen Vorteil für beide bringt. Etwas anderes ist Transfer-Traffic. Das heißt, mein Provider B bietet mir als Provider A an, dass er auch alles, was er an anderen Providern erreicht, für mich durchleitet. Und dieser Transfer-Traffic ist das, was ich am Anfang bei meinem Uplink eingekauft habe. Das heißt, das ist kostenpflichtiger Traffic. Aber ich schaue dann als ISP, zu welchen anderen ISPs läuft eigentlich mein Traffic, wo werfe ich meinem Uplink besonders viel Geld zu, weil es gibt einen großen deutschen Telekommunikationsanbieter mit relativ langer Erfahrung in dem Bereich. Er hat nun mal sehr viele Benutzer. Das heißt, da gehen vor allem Daten hin. Und dieser ISP kann ja daran interessiert sein, dass seine Benutzer auf meine Server schnell zugreifen können. Also es ist in seinem Sinne, dass er eine Verbindung zu mir herstellt.
Das heißt, bei T-Online dauert vieles so scheiße lang, weil T-Online keinen Bock hat, an andere Provider Geld zu zahlen?
T-Online betreibt selbst kein Netz. T-Online ist eine Firma, die die Endnutzer anschließt. Das eigentliche Netz wird von der Deutschen Telekom AG weiterhin betrieben.
Und warum dauert es teilweise tierisch lange, wenn ich per T-Online auf irgendeinen Server zugreifen will?
Im Internet, wenn da so 20 Hosts dazwischen sind, die man mit RaceRoute sehen kann, dann kann es an alle möglichen hängen. Aber es kann auch einfach sein, der letzte größere Ausnahmezustand im deutschen Internet war die Freigabe von Wochen 2. Da flogen den beteiligten Provider doch mal die Leitungen eher in den roten Bereich. Und da war gerade die Telekom auch sehr deutlich daran beteiligt, weil die haben einfach mal wirklich viele Benutzer.
Aber die Telekom pflegt doch ein bisschen anderes Verhalten, was so Peering mit anderen Providern betrifft in Deutschland. In welcher Form nehmen die am CIX-Teil? Also das CIX sollte man vielleicht noch kurz erläutern.
CIX steht für Commercial Internet Exchange. Davon gibt es das D6 in Frankfurt. Das wird vom EcoEVO betrieben. Dann gibt es in Frankfurt noch das MEFFM.
Was war MEFFM?
Metropolitan Area Exchange. Das wird von MCI WorldCom betrieben. Dann gibt es in München noch das INXS. Das wird von ECRC Cable & Wireless betrieben. Die Telekom ist nur in München am INXS präsent. Da gab es wohl persönliche Vorbehalte zwischen dem EQEV, dem Betreiber des DSIX und der Telekom.
Ich habe noch nicht verstanden, was DSIX macht.
Da können Provider ihre Router hinstellen. Das sind einfach mal definierte Räumlichkeiten, wo man Platz in einem 19 Zoll Schrank mieten kann. Da können die Provider dann zwischen ihren Routern Traffic austauschen, ohne dass sie dafür nun extra Leitungen legen müssten. Weil sonst habe ich vielleicht das Problem, dass ich mit einem Provider in München Daten austauschen will und das mal richtig viel Geld für eine Leitung kostet.
Und kostet das abgesehen von der Anmietung des Rackspaces noch Geld?
Das hängt halt von den Vereinbarungen zwischen den Providern ab.
Aber sind die jetzt für alle diese vier eben genannten Routern unterschiedlich?
Der SIX stellt im Prinzip nur den Platz im Rack und unter Umständen Switchports bereit. Da gibt es ein öffentliches Ethernet, an das sich dann die Mitglieder anschließen können. Da wird dann teilweise preislich unterschieden, ob der Porn nun 10 MBit oder 100 MBit ist. Und solche Schweine rein. Und das ist auch gar nicht so billig, wie man sich jetzt so ein bisschen Platz für so einen Router vorstellt. Aber was dann für Vereinbarungen unter den ISPs für die Peering ausgehandelt werden, ist eigentlich gar nicht mehr Sache des Betreibers der Räumlichkeiten.
Achso, das heißt, das ist tatsächlich nur die ganz grobe Struktur. Und da gilt nicht einfach jeder mit jedem und wie er will, sondern da muss jeder mit jedem noch vertraglich regeln, in welche Richtung welche Daten kosten oder nicht kosten.
Was gibst du mir für deinen Fisch? Auf jeden Fall ist das Zix irgendwie der Ort, dass wenn da irgendwie eine Bombe einschlägt, dann läuft erstmal eine ganze Weile lang ziemlich wenig in Deutschland.
Naja, aber das läuft dann halt viel früher auch über die USA. Also ich erinnere mich an die Zeiten, wo beispielsweise der DFN, das deutsche Forschungsnetz, mit niemandem anders Peeringabkommen hatte. Und aller Traffic, sagen wir, von dem Institut, wo ich arbeitete, die fortmäßig über Washington geroutet wurde.
Aber das ist halt schon eine Zeit lang auch noch so, ne?
Ja, das kann einem auch heute noch passieren.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall einer der deutschen Flaschenhälse. Das sieht man eben auch dann, wenn man jetzt wirklich eine Verbindung zu einem Rechner aufbauen will, der mehrere Provider von einem entfernt ist. Also nicht nur mehrere Computer, das ist ja normal, sondern auch mehrere Provider, die dann halt alle komische Peering-Verträge miteinander haben. Dann hoppst du halt das Paket erstmal von deiner Leitung nach Frankfurt. Dann wird es irgendwie nach New York und dann nochmal durch den CIA in Virginia geschickt. Dann geht es wieder über Oslo nach Finnland und dann ist es wieder in Frankfurt. Dann wird es nochmal nach Prag geschickt, um nochmal nach Frankfurt zu kommen.
Das stimmt schon, aber trotzdem, also auf die Übertragungszeit wirkt sich das nur dann aus, wenn wirklich viel Traffic auf einer Verbindung ist. Ansonsten ist die räumliche Entfernung nicht die entscheidende Größe.
Aber es ist ein bisschen widersinnig, kommt es mir trotzdem vor.
Ja, es ist teuer. Es ist einfach teuer.
Es ist nicht nur teuer, sondern es ist ja deswegen teuer, weil diese Leitungen, die man anmietet, je nach Bandbreite und je nach Strecke, kosten die richtig Geld. Und wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen, dass es also entsprechend, dass es im Moment eine knappe Ressource ist, weil nun mal Europa und Amerika nicht durch unendlich viele Leitungen, sondern durch endlich viele Leitungen verbunden sind und deswegen diese Leitungen einen relativ hohen Preis haben, also müsste man doch eigentlich ökonomisch sagen, dass die Datenpakete so wenig wie möglich diese Leitungen belasten sollten.
Aber wir wissen doch, es geht unter Männern nicht nur um die Ökonomie, sondern auch um Ehre, nicht wahr? Und der DFN fand zum Beispiel, es sei unter seiner Würde, Peering-Abkommen mit kommerziellen Providern zu haben.
Ja, aber das meinte ich doch. Ich meine, Ehre, diesen Begriff, den kenne ich eben aus irgendwelchen...
Einfach mal eher als Kapitalismus bezeichnen, weil zum Beispiel das DFN dachte von sich aus, dass sie keine Peelings auf Gegenseitigkeit, außer mit den 8, 12 ursprünglichen Mitgliedern des D6 hatten. Aber man konnte als ISP natürlich jederzeit gegen Bezahlung horrender Summen eine Leitung ins DFN schalten.
Ja, aber das klingt für mich doch so, als hätte das DFN das ja selbst eigentlich aus öffentlichen Geldern finanziert. Und insofern hier gar keinen... Ich meine, dürfen die überhaupt Tone machen damit?
Nee, das ist ein Verein, das stimmt schon.
Ja, ebenso. Und dass die sozusagen... Sie sagen jetzt mal wieder diesen Begriff, ich hoffe, ihr nehmt mich übel, aber in etwas mafiöser Manier, eben ihre Kumpels, die sie irgendwann mal mit drin hatten, dazu benutzt haben, um Geld zu drucken.
Okay, aber die kriegen natürlich von ihren Mitgliedern Beiträge für die Bandbraten, die die dabei sind.
Ja, aber dann geht es nicht um die Ehre, sondern es geht um Geld. Also, den Begriff mit der Ehre, das klingt irgendwie nett, aber...
Man kann lange darüber streiten, was nun genau der Grund ist. Tatsache ist, das Routing im Internet basiert nicht unbedingt auf den technischen Anforderungen, wie kommt ein Paket so schnell wie möglich irgendwohin, sondern ist im Wesentlichen auf vielen Verträgen vieler Firmen mit vielen unterschiedlichen Interessen, die sich auch täglich ändern. Und das ist eben auch ein Grund, warum es eben manchmal mit den Verbindungsgeschwindigkeiten oder überhaupt mit den Verbindungen als solchen manchmal nicht so klappt.
Ja und damit haben wir es 23 Uhr abends. Bitte braucht es niemanden, der dumme Fragen stellt. Chaosradio 54, wir reden über das Internet und zwar wie es geht und zwar im Großen und nicht, mein Modem geht nicht, wenn ich auf ON drücke. Wo wollten wir jetzt, was war, wo waren wir? Wir waren noch bei der Nummervergaberei, nicht?
Unser gerade größer werdender Beispiel-ISP hat jetzt gerade einen Karton Adressen vom, sagen wir, RIP bekommen und hat seine Routern an den Austauschpunkten stehen und jetzt erzählt er den anderen ISPs, mit denen er appiert, dass er eine bestimmte Liste von Adressen nun hat. Dieses nennt man ein BGP-Announcement. Das Routing-Protokoll, das dort verwendet wird, ist im Allgemeinen BGP. Das Border Gateway-Protokoll, inzwischen aktuelle Version 4 Plus. Und damit werden im sogenannten Backbone in der Default-Free Zone, die so heißt, weil die Router dort keine Default-Route mehr haben im Allgemeinen, damit werden die Präfixinformationen ausgetauscht. Ein Router in der Default-Free Zone hat im Allgemeinen die komplette Routing-Tabelle des Internet. Das sind im Moment bei IPv4 ungefähr 88.100 und ein bisschen Routen. Und das kostet RAM, das kostet Rechenzeit, die im Auge zu behalten, welche Route denn wo lang geht und immer den schnellsten Weg zu finden. Oder überhaupt zu bemerken, wenn einer, den man für möglich hält, defekt ist. Und das führt zu nicht geringen Problemen im Backbone-Routerbereich. Die Dinger haben inzwischen absolut absurde Mengen CPU-Leistung und RAM. Und daher bekommt man als ASP vom Raipe immer nur möglichst große Happen, sogenannte Allokationen, damit eben im Backbone-Bereich die Routen nicht mehr so rasant weiter wachsen, wie sie das vor fünf Jahren noch getan haben.
Aber das wird nicht mehr lange funktionieren, so was.
Wie verspricht man sich Abhilfe?
Kurzfristige Abhilfe ist das Verfahren, dass man nur noch große Blöcke zuteilt, damit die Menge der Präfixe nicht mehr so schnell wächst. Die langfristige Abhilfe wird IPv6 sein, wo man einen deutlich größeren Schwerpunkt auf die Zusammenfügbarkeit, die Aggregierbarkeit von Routen gelegt hat, um im Backbone-Bereich die Anzahl der Routen herunterzuschrauben. Das Ziel sollte es sein, nur noch eine Route pro im Backbone vertretenen ISP zu haben. Das ist ein schöner Wunschraum, aber selbst wenn wir nur noch 10 pro angeschlossenem ISP hätten, wäre das schon eine deutliche Verbesserung im Vergleich zu 88.000 Routen, die wir im Moment haben.
Okay, wir waren eben bei der ICANN. Da gab es John Postel, der hat die Top-Level-Domains verwaltet und der hat irgendwann gesagt, ich fände es gut, wenn es 500 Top-Level-Domains mehr gäbe, weil dann wäre der Stau, sag ich mal, weg. Das fanden ganz viele Leute doof, insbesondere die, die daran Geld verdienen, dass es nicht so viele gibt. Und der Mann ist tot. Was natürlich in keinerlei Zusammenhang miteinander steht. Was ist danach passiert? Beziehungsweise wann war das?
Also 1995 hat er diesen Vorschlag gemacht. Da hat er den ersten sogenannten Internet-Draft vorgelegt, der dafür plädierte, 500 neue TLDs einzuführen. Und damit hat er zwei Dinge bezweckt. Zum einen wollte er halt die drohende Namensknappheit beseitigen. Und zum anderen wollte er, was er eine Funktionsüberlastung des Domainnamensystems nannte, aufheben. Ursprünglich waren Domainnamen nur dazu da, eine nutzerfreundliche Adresse zu schaffen, dass wir nicht IP-Nummern auswendig lernen müssen, sondern stattdessen Namen verwenden können, um Rechner anzusteuern. Die Nutzer, vor allem die Kommerziellen, haben sozusagen die Funktion der Domainnamen erweitert, darum, dass sie das auch als richtige Adresse verstanden haben. Eine Adresse, die viel Geld wert ist, wie eine in der Innenstadt oder so. Und das wollte er wieder aufheben, indem er eben ganz viele neue Top-Level-Domains einrichtet, sodass die Konfusion so groß ist, dass es wieder beliebige Namen sind, wie das ursprünglich auch der Fall gewesen ist. Dagegen haben sich dann ganz viele Leute gewehrt, unter anderem eben die OECD und die WIPO und wen nicht vorher noch alles aufzählte. Und dann haben die Ingenieure, die Väter des Internets, eingesehen, dass sie das nicht mehr so freihändig entscheiden können, wie sie das vorher gemacht haben, und sich mit den realweltlichen, machtvollen Organisationen dieser Welt zusammensetzen müssen und haben dann versucht, unterhalb von einer Regierungs- also Einflussnahme der Regierungen, eine Organisation zu schaffen, die sozusagen demokratischer darüber befindet, was man jetzt mit dem Domainnamensystem macht. Das ging so zwei Jahre, wurden verschiedene Memoranden formuliert und als es dann soweit war, als man sich darauf geeinigt hatte, in der Schweiz eine internationale Organisation zu schaffen, die das Domainnamensystem verwalten sollte, ist die amerikanische Regierung eingeschritten. Der amerikanischen Regierung hat das aus zwei Gründen nicht gefallen. Zum einen, dass die Verwaltung des Domainnamensystems aus den USA ausziehen sollte und nach Europa verfrachtet werden sollte. Und zum anderen hat es ja nicht gefallen, weil die WIPO und die ITU damit drin hingen. Die Amerikaner wollten nicht das UN-Unterorganisationenzugriff aufs Internet bekommen, weil, wie man ja weiß, die UNO in Amerika nicht besonders beliebt ist.
Darum zahlen sie auch nicht, ne?
Unter anderem, ja. Es hat denen alles nicht gefallen, dann ist die amerikanische Regierung halt eingeschritten und hat selber Vorschläge gemacht. Und zwar hat sie einen sogenannten Request for Comment, also zu sagen, ja.
Wie kann überhaupt die amerikanische Regierung über einem demokratischen Medium einschreiten?
Das ist eine interessante Frage. Ich würde behaupten, das verhält sich im Internet nicht anders als sonst in anderen weltpolitischen Fragen auch. Die amerikanische Regierung kann immer so viel tun, wie ihr zugestanden wird von den anderen. Die bezieht ihre Autorität nur aus dem Umstand, dass die anderen einfach feige Schweinehunde sind.
Aber liegt das nicht auch ein bisschen an der technischen Struktur, die eben noch relativ hierarchisch einfach mal ist?
Du meinst, der Zugriff auf den Woot Server A, den hatte sie ja zu der Zeit nicht, den hat sie ja erst beansprucht. Die Amerikaner haben gesagt, wir haben das Internet geschaffen, mit unseren Mitteln ist es entstanden. Und deshalb gehört es uns. Ihr dürft jetzt zwei irgendwie mitmachen.
Das ist ja sowas wie katholische Kirche.
Wer war der formal juristische Betreiber des Woot Name Eserers vorher?
Erst AYANA und dann NSI, Network Solutions Inc.
John Postel hat irgendwann, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, um was es ging, einfach nur um seine Macht zu demonstrieren, die Administratoren von der Hälfte der Woot Name Server dazu gebracht, Änderungen vorzunehmen.
Die haben dann nicht mehr auf das Woot Zone File gezeigt, sondern auf den, den er betrieben hat. Dazu muss ich mal sagen, es gibt 13 Woot Server auf der Welt. Das ist sozusagen die Wurzel des Domain-Namen-Systems, das sind die Daten...
Sprich ruhig weiter, wenn Andi...
Wenn der Huwam sind, soll ich mich nicht...
Nein, wir haben uns hier nur untereinander gerade verständigt. Das ist ja auch mal erlaubt.
Also es gibt 13 Woot Name Server.
Woot Server, genau. Das sind Datenbanken, die jeweils auf die zentralen Names Server der Top-Level-Domains verweisen. Also der ganzen ländereigenen.
Die Woot Name Server sind dafür zuständig, einem Anfragenden mitzuteilen, wer denn jetzt für DE zuständig ist, sowie das DENIG dafür zuständig ist, durch seine Names Server, einem Anfragenden mitzuteilen, wer jetzt zum Beispiel für...
Leck mich fett am Arsch.
Aber das tut das Woot-Zoom-Teil nicht. Das verweist immer nur auf die oberste Ebene eines Namensraums. Das verweist auf DE, aber nicht auf sagen, der www.orb.de.
Der hierarchisch gebliederte DNS-Raum sollte eigentlich so funktionieren, dass jeder Server nur auf die nächst tiefer liegende Hierarchiestufe verweist. Manchmal überspringt man allerdings auch dazwischen liegende Stufen.
Ok, und Forstell hat gesagt, ok, da steht dieser Root Server A statt irgendwo in den USA. Und Forstell hat gesagt, so jetzt gönnen wir uns den Spaß und schalten den mal ab.
Ja, das war, er hat es als Test deklariert damals. Aber da hat er mich quasi gezeigt, dass die Regeln, die da jetzt gelten, auch umgeworfen werden können. Bei Allgemeinen gilt das Root Zone File, auch Root Server A genannt, so gilt als die autoritative Wurzel des gesamten Domainnahmesystems. Und darüber hält die amerikanische Regierung auch heute noch die Hand.
Auf welches Ding hat er da umgeschaltet?
Auf dem, der bei ihm an der Uni in Los Angeles steht. Also etwa die Hälfte der Root Server steht in den USA.
Da halten die dann die Hand drüber und die Bundesrepublik Deutschland beispielsweise lässt sie gewähren.
Die EU ja.
Weil die im Zweifelsfall sonst einmarschieren würden. Was befürchtet die EU?
Ich habe neulich die Gelegenheit gehabt, es gibt im Wirtschaftsministerium jemand, der dafür zuständig ist. Und das GAC, das ist eines der Subgremien von ICANN, das Governmental Advisory Committee, da haben die Amerikaner irgendwann als Trostpflaster, als Alternative, dass das Ding eben an die UNO geht, haben sie gesagt, gut, dann nehmen wir eben die andere Regierung auch mit rein ins Gremium. Also als so eine Art, also ich würde das als auch eine Strategie ansehen, weil entweder man lässt die Leute mitbestimmen oder man gibt ihnen das Gefühl, dass sie mitbestimmen und lädt sie halt ein, dass sie auch mal mit einem Kaffee trinken. Und die Interessen der Europäer werden wohl sehr genau abgestimmt, beschränken sich, aber da sind sie sich komischerweise auch einig, also die Europäer sind sich ja normalerweise über gar nichts einig, aber in diesem Gremium sind sie sich sehr einig und das Einzelte, was sie eigentlich wollten, behandelt die EU. Und ja, ich meine, so kann man das doch, glaube ich, zusammenfassen. Das hat der Schüler uns heute auch...
Die wollen, dass die amerikanische Regierung die Macht aufgibt über das Internet. Das wollen sie.
Aber einfach nur nehmen. Ich meine, das ist ja nicht das, was sie tatsächlich tun, Janett.
Praktisch ist es so, dass das amerikanische Wirtschaftsministerium sowohl die Hand über ICANN hält und diese dormant authority, diese schlafende Autorität, beansprucht. Ich will sagen, wenn ICANN... Sollen wir jetzt eigentlich lieber mal weitermachen in der Reihenfolge? Die amerikanische Regierung hat dann gesagt, sie werden das jetzt mal alles regeln. Das mit der internationalen Organisation gefällt ihnen nicht, weil schließlich ist das Internet amerikanisch und großzügigerweise wollen sie die anderen jetzt irgendwie mitmachen lassen. Aber es gehört ihnen. Und die ganze Fachkompetenz sitzt in den USA. Also wir lassen alles da, wo es ist. Ausrufezeichen. Und dann haben sie den Vorschlag gemacht, eine Organisation zu gründen, die nicht nur die Domainnamen verwaltet, das Domainnamensystem, sondern den ganzen Nummernraum mit. Und diese Institution ist dann auch gegründet worden. Also der Protest war groß. Dann haben sie das ein bisschen nochmal neu formuliert, was sie davor hatten. Und haben dann 1998 ICANN gegründet. Und ICANN schreibt sich ICANN, Internet Corporation for Assigned Names and Numbers. Und die sind eben jetzt zuständig für das, was früher die sogenannte IANA machte.
Neben der würde man den Löffel abriechen.
Ja, John Postel sollte auch mitmachen dürfen, aber der ist dann ja leider im Prozess verstorben.
Jetzt ist die ICANN zuständig. Und wer kontrolliert die?
Das amerikanische Wirtschaftsministerium.
Ich verstehe das wirklich nicht. Warum belassen sämtliche anderen, wie auch immer, wer auch immer damit betraut, den USA die Kontrolle darüber? Das ist doch eigentlich das, was man nicht will. Also wenn irgendjemand die Kontrolle nicht haben soll, dann sind es die USA oder nicht?
Die haben das schon relativ interessant gemacht. Der Aufbau von ICANN, der unterscheidet sich von allen anderen internationalen Organisationen, die wir kennen. In den Statuten von ICANN steht beispielsweise drin, dass Regierungen grundsätzlich kein Stimmrecht besitzen, sondern lediglich ein Beratungsrecht haben. Und dieses Beratungsrecht ist den Regierungen auch nur deshalb zugestanden worden, weil die EU gedroht hat, sie würde diese ganze Veranstaltung andernfalls platzen lassen. Und daraufhin ist das GAC gegründet worden, das was Andi eben schon erwähnte, das Governmental Advisory Committee. Und da tummeln sich die Regierungen und regierungsnahe Organisationen drin.
Also das Stocken, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das Stocken, das kommt daher, dass Tim gerade auf den Tisch steigt.
Kannst du mir mal sagen, wie ich diesem spastischen Windows 98 System beibringe, mir mal Internet, 5, egal, auf jeden Fall kleiner 2000, irgendwie, was soll ich hier klicken? Er sagt mir irgendwie, er soll auf neue Verbindungen klicken.
Ja, ich komm mal rum, ich mach mal Musik und dann komm ich mal rum. So, Tim hat Internet, hier ist das Chaosradio 54. Wir reden über die ICANN, über die Namen und Nummernvergabe im Internet, die von den Amerikanern kontrolliert wird. Soll sich da jetzt irgendwas ändern?
Also die EU fordert das.
Die hat vor kurzem wieder ein Papier vorgelegt, wo sie sagt, verdammt noch mal, ihr Amerikaner, gebt endlich ICANN das Wut-Sound-Zeil frei.
Auf welches Papier spielst du da jetzt gerade an? Weil das hab ich nämlich etwas anders wahrgenommen. Ich hatte den Eindruck, die klopfen da so ein bisschen an der Tür und sind eigentlich damit happy, dass wenn sie eine TLD EU haben und ein bisschen mitreden können.
Bestimmt nicht. Es gibt eine Communication, so nennen die das ja immer, ihre Schriftstücke da bei der EU vom Frühjahr dieses Jahres. Und darüber hat jetzt das GAC, das Governmental Advisory Committee, auch noch mal getagt und hat das Ganze bekräftigt. Man ist völlig standhaft und fordert und die amerikanische Regierung kann sich überlegen, ob sie jemals darauf antwortet oder nicht.
So jetzt sitzen in dieser ICANN Direktoren aus aller Herren Länder.
Ja, aus vielen jedenfalls.
Aus vielen Ländern. All diese Länder zusammen sind nicht in der Lage, den USA diese Kontrolle abzunehmen?
Also ICANN ist schon noch relativ stark amerikanisch kontrolliert.
Wie stark? Also zu was für einem Prozentsatz sitzen da Amerikaner drin?
Das ganze Staff, also alle Mitarbeiter, sind glaube ich ausschließlich Amerikaner. Die kommen zum überwiegenden Teil von der Harvard Law School, die auch aktiv ist im Bereich Internetforschung, also so eine Art Begleitforschung zur Entstehung von ICANN-Macht und halt auch Mitarbeiter stellt. Viele Rechtsanwälte, die um ICANN herumkreisen, sind auch alles Amerikaner mit besten Verbindungen ins Wirtschaftsministerium.
Also warum klemmen wir uns davon nicht ab? Warum klemmen wir uns nicht einfach? Warum kappen wir nicht die Kabel über einen großen Teil? Das ist ein bisschen blöd, dann kann ich nicht über.
Anlässlich der Diskussion um die neuen Top-Level-Domains muss man natürlich anmerken, dass es da draußen in diesem IPv4-Netz, das man als Internets kennt, bereits alternative Top-Level-Domains existieren. Es hindert ja niemand, einen daran zu vereinbaren. Ich habe jetzt hier meine Top-Level-Domain.ccc und eine Liste von dafür zuständigen Nameservern zu veröffentlichen und Leute, die diese Nameserver dann berücksichtigen, können dann auf die neue Top-Level-Domain.ccc zugreifen.
Aber das könnte mir dann passieren, dass im Zweifelsfall America Online gesagt kriegt, da greifen wir mal nicht drauf zu und dann kann kein AOL-User weltweit die Top-Level-Domain.ccc ansteuern.
Das ist nicht ganz so. Das Problem ist, dass der User bei sich einstellen müsste, dass er jetzt.ccc von folgendem Nameserver zugreifen möchte. Das könnte AOL natürlich immer noch sperren, indem sie treffig zu diesem Host sperren, aber das mit dem Sperren und Filtern funktioniert in diesem IPv4-Internet schon mal eher gar nicht. Die von Benutzergruppen genutzt, betrieben, erweitert, umstrukturiert und im Allgemeinen betrieben werden.
Und warum komme ich da nicht ran? Also, oder welche sind es? Ich kenne keine sonst.
Ich möchte jetzt hier gerade kein konkretes Beispiel nennen, aber z.B. die domain.ccc wäre etwas, was man dann auf dem Web-Server announceen könnte. Es wäre ein Eintrag, den der Benutzer in seiner Internet-Konfiguration eintragen müsste, auf welchen Nameserver er zugreift. Und da gibt es eben geschlossene Benutzergruppen, die genau dieses tun. Die machen allerdings im Allgemeinen vergleichsweise wenig Farbung für sich selbst, sonst wären sie keine geschlossene Benutzergruppe.
Ja, aber das ist doch eigentlich genau das, was ich haben möchte. Also ich möchte doch was Unkontrolliertes oder Unreglementiertes, zumindest von irgendwelchen Wirtschaftsministerien in irgendwelchen Ländern, denen ich nicht traue, Unkontrolliertes haben. Also warum findet das nicht Verbreitung?
Das Problem ist, dass der technische Aufwand und die Qualifikation, die man haben muss, um das überhaupt einzurichten, doch eher nicht gering ist. Wenn man ein paar Jahre in diesem Internet arbeitet, tatsächlich auch auf ASP-Innen erarbeitet, wird man feststellen, dass die wenigsten Leute ihre Name-Server, Mail-Server und sonstigen Server auch nur annähernd im Griff haben. Gerade Name-Server-Stellen für viele Betreiber von Zaubern da draußen machen ein echtes Rätsel da. Und teilweise ist es eher Glückssache, dass es funktioniert. Heute hat es zum Beispiel Amazon getroffen gehabt. Die haben eine Umstellung gemacht und vorher nicht drüber nachgedacht und dann hatten sie ein Problem.
Jetzt Kurzinfo.
Mit dem Wetter, die Temperaturen sinken in der Nacht auf 10 bis 5 Grad, es ist wolkig und gelegentlich regnet. Es morgens wechselnd bewölbt, morgens, morgen, wechselnd bewölbt, aber kaum Regen bei maximal 19 Grad. Die Meldung mit Gerald Kötterheim.
Berlin droht morgen ein Verkehrschaos. Tausende Trucker und Taxifahrer aus ganz Deutschland wollen mit einer Sternfahrt gegen die Ökosteuer und die hohen Spritpreise protestieren. Die Polizei empfiehlt Berufspender mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln zu fahren. Die Berliner Verkehrsbetriebe und die S-Bahn bieten verbildigte Tickets an. Nach den Grünen hat auch die Bundestagsfraktion der SPD die Rentenreformpläne von Arbeitsminister Riester gebildigt. Riester königte an, er werde noch in dieser Woche Union und FDP zu einer neuen Konsensrunde einladen. Das Ergebnis der Präsidentschaftswahlen in Jugoslawien soll morgen bekannt gegeben werden. Vorab gaben sich sowohl das Lager um Präsident Milošević, als auch die Opposition um den Kandidaten Kostunica Siegesgewiss. Der israelische Ministerpräsident Barak und der palästinensische Präsident Arafat sind am späten Abend zusammengekommen. Beide wollen versuchen, den stockenden Friedensprozess wieder in Gang zu bringen. Das Treffen findet in Baraks Privathaus statt. An Bord einer Sondermaschine mit Fußball-Champions League-Sieger Real Madrid hat es eine Panik gegeben. Auf dem Flug nach Düsseldorf hatte die Boeing wegen eines Druckverlustes innerhalb von einer Minute 5000 Meter an Höhe verloren. Alle Insassen, darunter auch Fans und Pressevertreter, kamen mit dem Schrecken davon. Real tritt am Mittwoch bei Bayer Leverkusen an.
Achtung, Geheimen! Nur einmal noch öffnet der legendäre Freischwimmer in Berlin-Kreuzberg seine Türen für eine super geheime Delikatessenparty. Delikett und ihre Überraschungsgäste erwarten euch am Mittwoch, dem 27. September, ab 20 Uhr. Der Freischwimmer ist schwer zu finden, aber nicht verzagen. Sucht in der Straße vor dem schlesischen Tor, direkt an der Spree. Sagt es weiter, aber verratet niemandem, wo ihr es gehört habt.
Schon gar nicht auf Heiz.
Ich muss jetzt auf einzelnen Wunsch des Tim das Musikprogramm kurz unterbrechen. Tim, bitte, was hören wir jetzt als nächstes? Lass uns mal laut, bitte. Die Wahrheit, ja, ok, dann bitte. Es ist auch nicht lang die Wahrheit.
Raus, Radio, bis der Abend kommt.
Im Weltraum siegte die SU, Herr. Das Chaosradio 54. Wir sprechen über die ICANN, immer Nummerns vergabe und Namensvergabe im Internet.
Und auch ein bisschen über die Politik und da können wir jetzt noch mal ganz kurz zu deiner Frage zurückkommen, warum denn die anderen Länder, die ja auch alle am Internet teilnehmen, nicht einfach der amerikanischen Regierung den Arsch aufreißen.
Im Weltraum hat schließlich schon die SU gesiegt.
Ob der Tatsache, dass die US-Regierung ja doch in relativ klar sichtbarer Weise eben versucht, die Kontrolle über den ANN-Node-Server und auch über andere ICANN-Funktionalitäten zu behalten. Und ich bin da gerade ein bisschen mit Janett ins Gefecht gekommen, weil sie sagte, aber die Europäer, die haben noch eine Resolution verabschiedet. Und die sagen doch, die Amerikaner sollen die Finger rausnehmen. Aber das stimmt nicht, sage ich, weil ich habe diese Resolution hier gerade auf dem Bildschirm. Das Einzige, was sie fordern ist der Übergang des Routeservers von der US-Regierung auf ICANN, das öffentliche Interesse, die Rolle der internationalen Registrierungsorganisation und der Übergangskarakter von ICANN. Nun hat das aber alles nichts damit zu tun, dass sie sagen, die US-Regierung sollte die Finger davon lassen. Sondern mein Eindruck, und ich habe mich mit diesem Mann unterhalten, der diesen Quatsch geschrieben hat, ist, die Europäer sind da hingekommen und haben gesagt, liebes, liebes ICANN, gib uns doch eine TLD EU, damit wir auch ein bisschen ICANN spielen können in Europa. Und dann hat ICANN gesagt, naja gut, bevor die Europäer hier böse werden, dann geben wir ihnen doch eine TLD zum Spielen sozusagen.
Die ist doch noch gar nicht vergeben.
Nein, die ist noch nicht vergeben, aber die ist ja so gut wie. Also, das zu Beständnis haben sie ja nun schon gemacht. Oder würdest du das noch anzweifeln?
Also, das mit dem so gut wie ist auch sehr relativ. Es gibt da ISPs in diesem Internet in Europa, die bereits dazu übergegangen sind, Domains unter der TLD.eu zu verkaufen, obwohl noch nicht mal endgültig entschieden ist, ob es sie überhaupt geben wird.
Na ja gut, aber es gibt ja auch Leute, die verkaufen ja jetzt schon Euromünzen und alles Mögliche. Also ich meine, schlimmer geht es immer. Aber ich meine, wir waren jetzt gerade mal bei dieser politischen Lage. Und die politische Lage ist eben nicht wirklich so, dass die Europäer da sagen, lass uns das dezentral über den Planeten verteilt organisieren, sondern die sagen, ihr macht da eine beschissene Konspiration und das wollen wir auch. Also das ist doch mein Eindruck jetzt. Würdest du dem widersprechen?
Was ich habe sagen wollen, ist, dass die EU nicht einverstanden damit ist, dass die Amerikaner die Hand über ICANN, Schrägstrich, Namens- und Nummernraum halten und dass sie dagegen protestieren. Dass sie das nicht allzu laut tun, da bin ich völlig mit ihr einer Meinung.
Da gehe ich mit dir d'accord.
Genau, genau.
Dann habe ich kurzfristig mich wieder umentschieden und es endete im Desaster.
Ja, aber das, was Sie sagen, was Sie im Moment anpisst, ist, dass der A-Name-Root-Server nicht mal bei ICANN ist. Aber es gibt doch, du sagst es auch selber, dieses schlafende Stimmrecht und so fort. Schlaflautimität.
Also es gibt ja bei ICANN noch eine ganze Menge von Einflussfaktoren der amerikanischen Regierung, wo eben der Betrieb des A-Name-Root-Servers wirklich nur einer ist.
Und in dieser Resolution protestieren sie aber nur gegen genau dieses eine und die tausend anderen Sachen. Die stehen hier einfach nicht und die haben sie da auch nicht ausgesprochen.
Also in der Langfassung, das ist ja nur die kurze.
Die Langfassung habe ich hier recht.
In der Langfassung steht an irgendeiner Stelle, dass sie dafür plädieren, dass ICANN irgendwann unabhängig ist.
Right.
Okay, sie plädieren, sie tun, sie machen.
Es nutzt nichts, das ist ja normal.
Gibt es da irgendeine Chance, dass sich da was dran ändert? Gibt es irgendeine Chance, die Amerikaner zurückzudrängen? Und wenn ja, wie sieht die aus?
Also in technischer Hinsicht kennt sich Ash sicher viel besser aus.
Ja, aber der chattet gerade.
Mir wurde gerade mitgeteilt, das wären dringend das Problem mit der Aufzeichnung hätten. Aber ich hoffe mal, das Problem wird von dem qualifizierten Personal an den Geräten noch gelöst werden.
Also bei mir ist alles in Ordnung hier.
Zu Debatte stehen alternative Roots und das wird irgendwann kommen, wenn das so weitergeht.
Also die Frage ist, nehmen wir mal an, wir kommen jetzt wieder mit dem Vorschlag, 500 neue TLDs einzufüllen und nicht wie Esther Dyson 5 oder vielleicht 10 oder so. Wo ist denn da das angebliche, also ICANN argumentiert ja, dass die nicht wegen der technischen Stabilität des Netzes ist? Das ist so die Standard-Ausrede, die ich bislang gehört habe. Ich weiß nicht, kennst du weitere, Ash?
Eigentlich ist das mit der technischen Stabilität wirklich nur eine Ausrede. Da gibt es kein konkretes, jetzt in naher Zukunft greifbares Limit. Wenn ich mir eine Domain angucke, wie DE. Die wird vom DENEC betrieben mit 3 Millionen Domains darunter. Dieses Zonenfall hat inzwischen absurde Ausmaße von mehreren 100 MB angenommen. Das ist noch handelbar. Man muss dickere Server hinstellen. Aber wenn ich mir angucke, wie momentan CPU-Leistungen, RAM-Größen und Preise dafür verfallen bzw. die technischen Möglichkeiten wachsen und die Preise verfallen, sehe ich auch bei 500 zusätzlichen Top-Level-Domains kein Problem für die Root-Name-Server. Diese Server haben zwar durchaus viel Last, aber diese Last ist unabhängig von der Anzahl der von ihnen geservten Zones, weil die Clients greifen zu. Das sind eine bestimmte Menge, die jetzt da draußen dieses Internet benutzen. Aber ob die nun nach drei unterschiedlichen Top-Level-Domains fragen oder nach immer wieder denselben, ist nun nicht wirklich ein Problem für diese Server.
Zurück zu ICANN. Da finden jetzt noch Wahlen statt. Erklär mal.
Also ICANN hat sich dem...
Also erstmal, was wird da gewählt? Also woraus setzen die ICANN zusammen?
Das Direktorium bestand bisher aus...
Es sind insgesamt 19 Direktoren. Es sind 18 Direktoren und ein Oberhäusling. Die Hälfte der Direktoren werden durch die Unterorganisation von ICANN gestellt. Das ist einmal eine Unterorganisation, die für das Domainnahmesystem zuständig ist, eine andere... Dann die zweite, die für den Adressraum zuständig ist und die dritte für die Protokolle. Und die stellen jeweils drei Direktoren für das Board. Nein, es gibt drei Unterorganisationen. Die Idee war, so schreibt es die Satzung von ICANN vor, dass die Hälfte der Direktoren durch die Nutzer selbst gewählt werden soll. Die eine Hälfte sind die drei Unterorganisationen und die anderen sollen durch die Nutzer gewählt werden. Das ist schon eine kleine Revolution, sowas gab es bisher nicht. Dass die Nutzer einer Infrastruktur direkten politischen Zugriff auf die Verwaltung haben sollen. Und die Geschichte dazu lautet, dass die amerikanische Regierung auf jeden Fall verhindern wollte, dass andere Regierungen Zugriff auf ICANN haben, sie aber andererseits dem Druck aus Australien, Europa etc. nachgeben musste, die sich für eine Internationalisierung eingesetzt haben und dass man deshalb gedacht hat, die kleine Lösung ist die, dass man eine gewisse Demokratisierung dadurch einfügt, dass man einen kleinen Haufen von Nutzern auch machen lässt.
Aber das ist ja jetzt die zukünftige Zusammensetzung des Direktoriums. Die bestehende ist ja erstmal gegeben durch den Gründungsprozess von ICANN. Kooption. Und das heißt?
Dass die, die da schon immer im Boot saßen, sich Leute gesucht haben, von denen sie fanden, dass die dazu passen und den gleichen Stallgeruch mitbringen.
Ja, das ist ja nun eine sehr freundliche Formulierung. Also das heißt doch, naja, ich meine, man könnte es ja nun auch ein bisschen anders formulieren. Man könnte auch sagen, die amerikanische Regierung hat irgendwie diesen Laden gesagt, ok, jetzt gibt es hier irgendwie ICANN als formelle Firma, nach kalifornischem Recht als Non-Profit-Firma. Und ja, jetzt haben wir den und den und den und die sitzen da jetzt drin. Und die ICANN-Statuten fordern ja geradezu, dass eben von dir beschriebene Prozedere auch unter der Überschrift bottom-up Legitimierung der gefällten Entscheidung. Das heißt, die Entscheidung, die ICANN fällt, sollen tatsächlich durch Nutzerbeteiligung legitimiert sein, wobei in welcher Form, das ist da eben nicht so ganz genau spezifiziert. Und insofern stand da aber schon, denke ich, nicht nur eine Revolution, sondern da stand auch einfach mal da stand was in den Statuten, was nicht umgesetzt war. Und es haben sich halt verschiedene Leute da lange genug darüber aufgeregt. Und dann haben sie gesagt, gut, dann müssen wir mal was machen. Und so, glaube ich, kann man behaupten, ist diese At-Large-Wahl jetzt entstanden.
Ist das jetzt wesentlich anders als das, was ich gesagt habe?
Ein bisschen anders, ein bisschen anders.
Ich meine, es ist gut, wenn du es normal erzählst.
Es ist ja kompliziert alles.
Ja, weil Stahlgeruch finde ich zu freundlich. Stahlgeruch hieße so viel wie Willkür auf Basis persönlicher Präferenzen. Es ist aber eigentlich Willkür auf Basis von Machtkalkül. Weil es geht hier ja nicht um irgendwie die Farbe der Steckdosen im Icann-Gebäude, sondern es geht hier um das weltweite Internet. Und da messe ich denen eine andere Bedeutung zu. Und da finde ich den Begriff Stahlgeruch einfach viel zu freundlich.
Und auch uns auch unsachlich.
Also okay, das sollen die Hörer entscheiden, ist ja auch egal. Gut, was sie also gemacht haben, ist, sie haben diese Wahl angekündigt, von denen sie jetzt, also die jetzt tatsächlich fünf der insgesamt 19 Direktoren weltweit in das Direktorium als sogenannte At-Large-Repräsentate...
Ja, sie haben das erstmal wieder reduziert, ne? Also von den neun, die die Nutzer eigentlich wählen sollten und die die Hälfte des Direktoriums stellen sollten, sind sie erstmal wieder abgewichen und haben gesagt, fangen wir lieber mal mit fünf an.
Es ist so eine Art Demokratieleid, wäre die freundliche Formulierung. Also ich finde es fast sachlicher zu sagen Legitimationssimulation, weil es ja darauf hinausläuft, dass ICANN eben unter dem Druck der Legitimierung stand. Du hast gerade meinen Kopfhörer runtergesprungen.
Die bittere Wahrheit ist, dass die Mehrzahl der Direktoren von ICANN auf die Direktoren, die durch die Nutzer gewählt werden sollen, überhaupt keine Lust haben und deshalb das Ganze lieber wieder abschaffen wollen.
So ist es.
Das ist jetzt die Kulturerklärung wiederum.
Ist auch okay.
Also, wird was passiert? Die haben also die Wahl angekündigt. Die haben gesagt, werdet mal Mitglied und wählt mal irgendwie. Sie haben diese Ankündigung aber nicht besonders laut in die Welt hinausgeschrieben, sondern sie haben irgendwo auf ihrer Webseite da unten rechts so einen kleinen Button gehabt, so ungefähr. Und haben es also ja schon bekannt gegeben, aber im Wesentlichen haben das eigentlich nur Leute mitbekommen, die unmittelbar mit ICANN zu tun haben oder hatten. Das sind eben die erwähnten Unterorganisationen für Adressierungen, für Namen und so weiter und so fort. Und eigentlich, wahrscheinlich eher durch zufällige Beiwohnung von Journalisten, ist das Ganze überhaupt ein bisschen öffentlich geworden. Und dann ist eben was passiert, was?
Ja, ICANN hat gedacht, es werden 5.000 bis 10.000 etwa.
Genau. Und dann sind auf einmal insgesamt 70.000 Leute registriert. Und das hat ja eben damit zu tun, dass eine Menge Leute, also ein paar Journalisten, waren wohl in Yokohama auf dem letzten ICANN-Meeting. Also ich weiß nicht, wie es eigentlich zustande gekommen ist. Es gab so auch innerhalb von Amerika den einen oder anderen Artikel, weil ein paar Leuten das nicht gefallen hat, dass dieses Direktorium ein bisschen selbstherrlich agiert und eben eigentlich Außenwelteingaben nicht wirklich ernst nimmt. Die haben auch eine ganz interessante Entscheidungskultur, die im Board of Directors, also der Vorstand der Tag zwar öffentlich, aber im Wesentlichen das, was sie öffentlich tun, ist Entscheidungen konsensual verkünden. Also nicht, dass sie sich da streiten und irgendwie diskutieren, sondern die verkünden da irgendwas, was sie vorher ausgeklümmelt haben. Und das erweckt natürlich auch innerhalb von Amerika mal so die eine oder andere Nachfrage, ob sie noch alle Tassen im Schrank haben. Das ist mal salopp zu formulieren.
Das ist wesentlich dazu beigetragen, dass diese Geschichte überhaupt bekannt worden ist, die Spiegelkampagne, die irgendwann im Frühsommer des Jahres losgetreten wurde. Sonst wüsste vermutlich heute noch niemand davon.
Und es haben sich dann, also das, was jetzt ein bisschen merkwürdig gelaufen ist, es sind 35.000 europaweit registrierte Wähler, von denen knapp über 20.000 Deutsche sind. Insofern, das spricht natürlich schon für diese Medientheorie, aber in anderen Ländern gab es natürlich auch Aufrufe. Aber in Frankreich zum Beispiel sind es, glaube ich, 2.500 oder so. Also es ist deutlich, ja, Faktor 10 weniger. Und in anderen Ländern, also auch die Italiener, die haben auch die Zahl geschrieben, ich glaube, 1.600 oder sowas.
Vielleicht sollte man noch mal sagen, also wählen können nur die, die sich bis Ende Juli haben als Mitglieder registriert und die sich dann auch noch bis 8.
September aktiviert haben.
Ja, ihre Mitgliedschaft aktiviert haben. Also all die, die heute erst oder in den letzten Wochen von ICANN gehört haben, haben keine Möglichkeit mehr zu wählen. Und das bringt viele auch zurecht auf.
Und der Unterschied ist eben, oder das Prozedere ist das, das registriert heißt, man hat da seine Daten angegeben und aktiviert heißt, man hat den auf dem Postweg dann zugeschickten PIN-Code zusammen mit seinem Passwort und was nicht alles dazu genutzt, um sich eben zu aktivieren. Nun war der Trick der, dass ICANN wie gesagt überhaupt nicht wirklich diese Wahl offenbar ernst genommen hat oder damit gerechnet hat, dass das irgendwie jemand mitbekommt. Und den ist dann zwischendurch schlicht das Porto ausgegangen, um die Umschläge mit den PIN-Briefen rauszuschicken. Die hatten einfach mal keine Kohle mehr. Haben sie irgendeinen Sponsor gesucht? Also so zumindest ist die Darstellung.
Die haben mit 5.000 bis 10.000 Wählern gerechnet. Dann hatten sie eine Spende, die haben sie genutzt, um diese Wahl auszurichten. Diese Spende beträgt 200.000 Dollar und kommt von der Markel Foundation, eine amerikanische Stiftung. Und allein um diese sogenannten PINs zu verschicken, auf dem Postwege, haben sie schon über 160.000 Dollar ausgegeben. Weil 160.000 Mitglieder, sie haben gerechnet 1 Dollar pro Brief, mindestens sind 160.000 Dollar weg gewesen. Da hat man noch keinen Server eingerichtet, nichts. Eine einzige Person bei ICANN ist für die Administrierung dieser Wahl zuständig. Die kriegt manchmal am Wochenende 10.000 Mails. Nur übers Wochenende. Und alle werden immer wütender, weil keiner reagiert und die vielen Pimps zum Teil nicht angekommen sind. Ich zum Beispiel habe auch keinen gekriegt. Ich bin zwar Kandidatin, aber keine Wählerin. Ich bin jetzt nicht mehr im Wählerverzeichnis, einfach rausgeflogen. Und das ist vielen anderen auch so gegangen. Also durch diese dilettantische Organisation der Wahl ist unendlich viel Ärger entstanden.
War das auch vielleicht ein bisschen Absicht, oder war es wirklich, dass da nur Leute rum dilettiert haben?
Ich glaube, da sitzen einfach Leute, die keinen Weitblick haben. Die haben gedacht, sie könnten jetzt mal so eine Testwahl machen im Internet. Die, die davon wissen, wählen und die anderen eben nicht. Sie wollten sowieso eigentlich nur Experten ansprechen. Und dann ist das halt ihnen plötzlich völlig aus der Kontrolle geraten, weil eben die Medien darauf angesprungen sind. In Europa der Spiegel. Und dann irgendwann ein paar Wochen später in Asien die Regierungen, die haben dann so einen nationalen Wettkampf losgetreten. Die Chinesen wollten auf jeden Fall mehr Mitglieder haben als die Japaner. Weil die haben natürlich gerechnet und gedacht, wenn wir am meisten Mitglieder haben, stellen wir den Direktor. Das haben wir aber noch nicht gesagt. Es gibt fünf Wahlkreise. Das sind jeweils die Weltregionen.
Wir haben gesagt, es gibt fünf Direktoren, die über die At-Large-Mitgliedschaft anstelle von neun gewählt werden. Weil fünf so eine schöne Zahl ist, hat ICANN gesagt, es gibt auch ungefähr fünf Kontinente. Dann haben sie den Finger in die Luft gehalten und fünf Kontinente benannt. Das ist ziemlich lustig, weil das hat mit dem, was man normalerweise unter den Kontinenten versteht, überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Die haben schon irgendeine Vorlage gehabt. Die haben sich das nicht einfach aus den Fingern gesogen.
Da gab es mal so ein Brettspiel, das heißt Risiko.
Nordamerika ist jetzt ein anderer Kontinent wie Südamerika. Asien ist, glaube ich, mit Australien zusammengewachsen. Und Europa ist so ungefähr das Zeug in der Mitte. Und dann gibt es noch die Afrika.
Ok, da finden jetzt die Wahlen statt?
Da haben dann erst mal Vorwahlen stattgefunden, weil da man ja quasi nicht wie bei einer normalen Wahl jetzt irgendwie tatsächlich da so wie man eben eine Wahl ausruft, sondern weil man ja eigentlich ein geschlossener Club ist und es auch bleiben wollte, hat man sich überlegt, da die Wahl ja wahrscheinlich sowieso niemand interessiert und wir es ja auch niemandem weiter erzählen, benennen wir mal Viber-Kandidaten vor, die dann automatisch Direktor werden für den Fall, dass überhaupt keiner fehlt.
Also es ist für den Fall, dass lauter Idioten kandidieren. Die hatten Angst davor, dass da lauter Leute antreten, die nicht im Mindesten qualifiziert sind.
Da sind ja auch ein paar, ne?
Ja, wir zum Beispiel.
Genau, wir sind total auf den Kopf gefallen. Aber wir sind immerhin hinreichend auf den Kopf gefallen, um die Prozedur, die dann, also das erinnert so ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, wer den Anhalter durch die Galaxis gelesen hat, da gibt es ja auch durchaus die Möglichkeit, die Baupläne für den Bau der Hyperraumumgehungsstraße einzugehen. Man muss nur, da ist diese Treppe, okay, die ist ein bisschen unbeleuchtet.
Nein, das war nur für das Haus, das war für Arthur's House. Also die Hyperraumumgehungsstraße, die lagen auf Alpha Centauri, und zwar 50 Jahre lang.
Aber nehmen wir mal an, man will also ICANN-Direktor werden, dann gibt es das Problematik, dass man erstmal die Vorwahl bestehen musste, und das heißt, mindestens zwei Prozent der Wählerstimmen bekommen musste, um insgesamt ein der zwei freien Plätze.
Es gibt nur sieben. Ja, soll ich nochmal anfangen?
Also es gibt insgesamt, nehmen wir mal an, Europa ist jetzt ein Kontinent, ein Wahlkreis, und da gibt es sieben Kandidaten für den Wahlkreis.
Von denen sind fünf schon festgelegt? Also die kann man wählen oder nicht? Und die anderen beiden, da kann man sogar wählen, wer diese beiden sein sollen.
Ja genau, das waren die Vorbahnen.
Das sind wir beide.
Genau. Ja, da gratuliere ich jetzt so. Und jetzt werdet ihr gewählt. Angenommen, ihr werdet gewählt. Was passiert da?
Nee, nur einer wird gewählt.
Nur einer wird gewählt. Also, angenommen, Janett wird gewählt.
Was passiert dann?
Frau Direktorin, was machen wir denn?
Das ist doch eh schon so zammtisch.
So Jan und nicht.
Ich denke, sobald ich das mitbekommen habe, habt ihr ja nun aufgrund eurer erfolgreichen Kandidatur in den letzten Wochen eine ganze Menge Mails bekommen aus aller Welt. Und da sind euch sicherlich ein paar interessante Fragen gestellt worden. Was waren denn da so?
Ich könnte da vielleicht mal so ein bisschen drüber...
Also ich glaube, ich habe am ersten Wochenende 15.000 bekommen. Und die, die ich danach lesen habe, waren alle, warum ich auf meine Mails nicht reagiere. Nein, mein Ernst. Da sind natürlich eine Menge Leute jetzt in Europa, die sich, zum Beispiel die Italiener, die fragen sich natürlich, und die haben das mich auch gefragt, ob denn das irgendwie alles hier mit rechten Dingen zugeht. Weil die ersten, oder die einstesten beiden Kandidaten, die überhaupt über die Freibau reinkommen, sind natürlich Deutsche, weil eben 20.000 deutsche Wähler die 34.000 europäischen dominieren ein bisschen. Und die Italiener mit ihren zaghaften, so um die 1.600 Wähler oder was, die fragen sich natürlich, ob sie jetzt nicht von den Deutschen überrannt werden und fühlen sich da auch nicht besonders wohl, weil, was man nur oft verstehen kann.
Gibt es denn eine Statistik, aus welchen Ländern eure Wähler kommen?
Nein, das nicht direkt.
Es gibt die insofern, als das eine der Bedingungen war, auch dass man eine bestimmte Anzahl der Stimmen außerhalb des eigenen Landes kommen muss. Wie viele waren das noch?
Eine.
Eine, dann haben wir irgendwie beide erfüllt.
Das klingt wirklich so, als hätten die nicht mit 70.000 die Hohen Rechte.
Von den 74 oder 75 Kandidaten, die das ursprünglich in Europa waren, gab es glaube ich nur vier oder fünf, die diese Bedingungen nicht erfüllt haben. Von daher, das teilen wir mit allen anderen. Das ist nicht wirklich eine Errungenschaft.
Ok, du wirst gewählt. Angenommen, du wirst gewählt. Was passiert dann, was machst du dann? Und vor allen Dingen, wie viel hast du dann zu Kamellen? Also wie viel Mitspracherecht hast du dann?
Na dann ist sie eine von 19. Und das heißt, wenn Janett dann eine Falschacht macht, wird sie von 18 Leuten entweder überstimmt oder sie formuliert es so schön diplomatisch.
Was denn?
Hab ich was Falsches gesagt?
Nee, also so ist es ja nicht. Erstens kann man ganz sicher damit rechnen, dass in den USA zum Beispiel auch ein kritischer Kopf gewählt wird. Die drei, die da im Moment am meisten Stimmen haben. Im Unterschied zu Europa ist in Amerika ja auch ein wirklicher Kritiker von ICANN offiziell nominiert worden. Auch dem werden gute Chancen nachgesagt. Und einer von denen wird das. Das heißt, es werden sich auf jeden Fall Allianzen unter den sogenannten At-Large-Direktoren, die jetzt durch diese Wahlen ins Direktorium kommen, werden sich sicher Allianzen bilden. Habe ich überhaupt kein Zweifel dran. Und die werden zusammen mit den anderen, die da auch noch reingewählt werden, kommen erstens die Mehrheitsverhältnisse deutlich verschieben. Die werden auch dafür sorgen, dass viele von den Dingen, die heute hinter verschlossenen Türen passieren, öffentlicher werden. Die Transparenz wird auf jeden Fall größer werden. Und außerdem sollen die meiner Meinung nach ja auch dafür sorgen, dass die Nutzer und vor allen Dingen die Mitglieder von ICANN, sich künftig selber organisieren und selber auch aktiv werden.
Blühende Landschaften, was genau schwebt dir da vor? Also was soll passieren? Du kommst ja jetzt hin und sagst so, jetzt wird hier aufgeräumt.
Das ist zum Beispiel eine der Diskussionen, die gerade auf einer Mailingliste, die heißt ICANN Europe und wird von FITO, vom Förderverein Informationstechnologie und Gesellschaft betrieben. Sehr kontrovers unter den europäischen Kandidaten. Also diese 70 Leute, die sind da denke ich schon alle drin. Und da wird eben darüber diskutiert, ob man jetzt einen, der ursprungsvolle Vorschlag lautete, European at Large Members Council. Ich hätte das gerne lieber als Forum, weil Council, das klingt immer gleich schon wie so eine Regierungsanspruch. Aber letztendlich geht es halt darum, die europäischen Nutzer zu organisieren. Und da können wir auch mal die Hörer fragen, welche Ideen sie dazu haben.
Das hat er elegant gemacht.
Das hat er wirklich elegant gemacht. Denn eigentlich ist das eine Sendung hier zu mitmachen.
Und das macht man unter diesem Terminal.
70 97 110 Was hättet ihr denn gerne, wie sich denn dann da was ändern soll, wenn wir denn dann ein wenig mit Spracherecht beide Namen und Nummer vergabelt im Internet haben? Ruf mal an hier. Och Mensch, es ist ja Mitternacht. Da kann ich ja ansagen lassen, wie die Sendung heißt, wenn meine Jingle-Maschine mich jetzt nicht im Stich lässt.
Aber die Rufnummer wolltest du ansagen.
Ja, die Rufnummer habe ich schon mal angesagt. Das ist die 0331. Das kann ich ja nochmal sagen. 0331 70 97 110 Und es ist tatsächlich so, dass sich die Jingle-Maschine irgendwie verabschiedet hat. Das hier ist der Blue Moon des Chaosradio 54. Verdammt, die Maschine macht mich krank. Chaosradio 54, wir reden über Icann, über die Namen- und Nummernvergabe im Internet. Und so heißt diese Idee zu. Chaosradio 54, auf der Witz immer noch.
Ja, was so die Distanz zu uns beteiligen betrifft, verweise ich nochmal kurz auf unseren IRC-Channel. Da müsst ihr euch auf den IRC-Server irc.ccc.de begeben und dort in den Channel Chaosradio rein hüpfen. Da lese ich gerade ein bisschen mit und ansonsten haben wir noch unsere Telefonnummer.
0331, Potsdam, 7097110.
Thorald, du bist dran.
Ich bin dran. Ich wollte mal fragen, was ich jetzt speziell für mich, wir sind unser eigener, oder was heißt für meine Firma, wir sind sozusagen unser eigener ISP, was ich durch die deutsche, wie soll ich sagen, durch diese zwei oder durch diese eins...
Aber Thorald, warte mal, jetzt hat Ash gerade sein Kopfhörer nicht auf gehabt. Fangen wir nochmal an mit der Frage zu, ich bitte auch vielmals um Entschuldigung.
Also ich arbeite in einer Firma, wir sind sozusagen unser eigener ISP. Was ändert sich durch diesen deutschen Direktor für meine Firma? Jetzt direkt gibt es da irgendwas, außer dass ich jetzt eine deutsche Vertretung im ICANN nenne habe?
Nicht zwangsläufig, aber was ich möglicherweise... Ich meine, darf ich fragen, an wem ihr jetzt peert?
Wir hängen übers Kolbnetz dran.
Okay, das heißt, ihr seid dann sozusagen nicht direkt ISP für andere, sondern nur...
Nur für uns selbst, wir hosten selber sozusagen.
Was sich möglicherweise ändert, ist, dass wir, denke ich mal, eine stärkere Dezentralisierung im Bezug auf das Namenssystem da zum einen reinbringen wollen. Und was insbesondere halt im Moment ein Problem ist, ist, dass der Namensraum im Moment unter uneinheitlichen Regeln im Bezug auf kommerzielle Fragen, das heißt, wenn du zum Beispiel jetzt, ich gehe mal davon aus, ihr habt irgendwelche Kunden, für die ihr wiederum Domains hostet, und diese Kunden, die werden ja sich irgendwelche Namen holen, damit sie eben Domains, damit sie eben schön aufwendbar sind. Und nehmen wir mal an, sie haben jetzt einen Namen, den sie nicht als eingetragenes Warnzeichen haben, eintragen lassen, sondern eben nur als Domain. Und jetzt kommt irgendein Unternehmen in Sagen wie Ägypten und hat diesen Namen aber als Warnzeichen vor 350 Jahren eingetragen, und jetzt wollen die den auf einmal haben. Und es gibt halt im Moment keine besonders einheitliche Prozedur dafür. Es gibt zwar einen Versuch einer einheitlichen Prozedur, aber de facto gibt es dann einen Gerichtsprozess. Und das Verfahren hängt letztendlich von der Laune eures, ich sag jetzt mal Dorfrichters oder von eurer lokalen Gerichtsbarkeit ab.
Ja genau, wir haben nämlich schon einen Fall.
Ja, und das ist natürlich, um es mal vorsichtig anzudeuten, etwas, was man eigentlich vermeiden sollte und auch vermeiden könnte, indem man eben den Namensraum ganz klar in Räume unterteilt, in denen eben bestimmte Spielregeln gelten. Und das heißt, wenn es Warnzeicheninhaber gibt, die wollen, dass in einem bestimmten Namensraum das gilt, dann muss man auch eine TLD, also eine Top-Label-Domain, zum Beispiel.tm einführen. Und wenn es eben kein einheitliches Recht auf diesem Planeten für Markenrecht gibt, dann muss man das eben in Region machen. Das heißt, dann müsste man eben auf der Secondary-Ebene sagen, dann heißt das eben.tm.de für die deutschen Markenrechtsinhaber und dasselbe eben für Ägypten, die Schweiz und Wien auch immer. Und damit könnte man eben die normalen Räume frei von diesem Stressraum halten, sodass sich ein Kunde oder ein Unternehmen oder wer auch immer sich eben ein Domain holt, sich ganz klar für einen Raum entscheiden kann und damit auch weiß, ob er dann sozusagen entweder hat eben Markenrecht oder nicht. Und wenn er das nicht hat, dann kann er ja auch in den Raum gehen, wo eben Markenrecht keine Anwendung findet in Bezug auf den Namensraum. Weil sonst drehen wir ja alle miteinander durch und bezahlen nur noch Juristen, die irgendwie...
Also mit Andi Malamagun mehr Rechtssicherheit.
Gut, und mit Janett Hoffmann?
Auf jeden Fall mehr Geschäfte für den ASDs. Weil wenn der Namensraum ganz erheblich wächst, kann man ja auch mehr Domainnamen registrieren und für dieses Registrieren auch Geld verlangen.
Ja, das ist richtig, wobei ich natürlich schon nicht nur dafür plädieren würde, neue TLDs einzuführen, die kommerzieller nutzen sind.
Das geht ja gar nicht um Geld. Es geht ja darum, dass überhaupt Verdienprovider auch damit Domainnamen verwalten.
Ja, das ist ja schon richtig. Aber das liegt ja auch daran, dass im Moment Domainnamen so eine Art Wirtschaftsgut sind. Nämlich, dass man da hingeht und ein Betrag X auf dem Tisch legt und dann hat man eben Name Y. Und nach meinen bescheidenen Vorstellungen würde ich eine Erweiterung des Domainnamens nicht nur zum Zwecke der Bereicherung der Beteiligten durchführen, sondern auch...
Das ist ein Effekt, Andi. Ich sag nicht, dass man den...
Ein Effekt und damit ein nettes Argument auch.
Ja, das mag ja ein Effekt sein, aber den muss es ja nicht zwangsdäufig geben. Man könnte ja auch explizit kommerzfreie CLDs einführen, die eben nicht diesen Spielregeln unterlegen sind und wo sich auch keiner daran bereichern soll, sondern die eben explizit als öffentlicher Raum...
Ja, weil der Namensraum gerade für kommerzielle Anwendungen, was ja auch viele Firmen betrifft, ist durch dieses Dotcom, was es bis jetzt nur existiert, mal in Anführungszeichen, sehr beschränkt. Und das fände ich schon gut, wenn es mehrere CLDs gäbe, wo man dann auch kommerzielle Bereiche ein bisschen mehr aufdrehen kann, wo man eben sieht, oha, der ist aus der EDV-Branche, der ist Baubranche, der ist Autopranche. Ich würde das begrüßen, ich würde das sehr begrüßen sogar.
Ja, aber im Moment stehen halt dadurch, dass die Kultur von ICANN durch die Direktoren, die alle mehr oder weniger aus Industriekreisen stammen, das kann man wohl schon so behaupten. Ich gucke dich an, Janett, weil du diesen ganzen Laden etwas mehr erforscht hast als ich schon.
Also das haben wir noch gar nicht erzählt. Der eigentliche Skandal, der in Yokohama ja beschlossen worden ist, besteht darin, dass man, wenn man eine neue Top-Level-Domain beantragen will, dafür 50.000 Dollar auf den Tisch nehmen muss.
dass überhaupt die ganze Kultur der neuen Top-Level-Domains, die im Moment dort diskutiert werden, eigentlich eine rein kommerzielle Diskussion ist, nämlich a. nur kommerzielle neue TLDs und b. das ganze Prozedere ist halt nur als Gelddruckmaschine für ICANN im Moment initiiert, weil die schlicht und ergreifend Kohle brauchen und auch genau wissen, dass wenn sie 500 neue TLDs haben, dass sie dann halt eher die Kontrolle verlieren und nicht jedes Jahr mal wieder 50.000 hier und 50.000 da.
Ich sage ja immer, der Cyberspace ist groß genug für alle, soll jeder sein Geschäft da machen, aber bitte nicht den anderen ihre Regeln aufdrücken. Sind Sie da einer Meinung, Herr Anrufer?
Ja, da bin ich mit Ihnen einer Meinung wirklich wahr, weil wir hatten ein Namesproblem und wir sollten dafür viel Geld bezahlen. Und ich weiß nicht, wie das ausgeht.
Ja, ich meine, was man halt klar machen muss, ist, dass das Namesystem im Netz wirklich nur als Orientierungssystem mal irgendwann grob eingeführt wurde und definitiv nicht als so eine Art gelbe Seiten oder sowas. Weil eben erstmal, also ich kenne auch jede Menge Unternehmen, die haben ihre Computer zum Beispiel nach den Namen von Kaufhäusern bedannt, einfach weil es praktischer ist, Parkar statt Kaufhof oder Herty zu nennen, als sie mit 192, 194 irgendwas anzureden.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, wir sind Dienstleistungsunternehmen, wir haben viele Kunden und wenn man denen einen Einträgen will, ist sie ein bisschen dieselbe oder jener IP-Adresse eingeben. Ein Name ist nun mal einprägsamer.
Klar, genau, das ist ja der Punkt. Aber ich meine, es geht ja jetzt darum, ihr geht jetzt in den Gerichtsverfahren und das Gericht hat jetzt zu entscheiden, inwieweit ihr sozusagen das Recht hattet, einen Namen zu wählen, den ein anderes Unternehmen irgendwann mal als Warnzeichen eingetragen hat. Und was die Juristen teilweise eben denken, ist, dass das Internet-Namensystem gleichbedeutend ist mit dem Produktnamenssystem, was es eben nicht ist. Weil es geht hier nicht um Produkte, sondern es geht hier um Computer und es geht hier um Websites, die man findet, weil man einen Namen eingibt. Und es ist nicht vergleichbar mit, ich gehe in ein Geschäft und sage einmal Coca-Cola, bitte. Und wenn ich deine Pepsi bekomme, dann kann ich den Laden verklagen oder so ein Schwachsinn. Und ich denke, das ist im Moment eine Diskussion, die man eben dadurch auch in die Hirne der Juristen ein bisschen besser bringen könnte, wenn man klarmacht, wir haben im Moment keine Spielregeln, die Warnzeichenrecht heißen im Internet. Wir müssten sie vielleicht einführen, gute Idee. Und dazu brauchen wir eben eine neue TLD, die heißt TM. Und solange ICANN sich da querstellt und so tut, als würde die WIPO, die Wirt und der Electro Property Organisation, also der Segen sein, der das alles regeln könnte, solange haben wir natürlich ein Problem. Und genau deswegen brauchen wir einen dieser beiden möglichen deutschen Kandidaten zusammen.
Ich drücke euch beiden die Daumen.
Danke, Thoralf. Wenn ihr mit uns sprechen wollt, könnt ihr es unter der Nummer hier.
0331 von Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Erstens hätte ich eine Frage und zwar, ich kann mir nicht denken, wenn man für eine Top-Level-Domain jetzt, sagen wir mal, 50.000 Dollar kassiert, ob ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe. Und jetzt ist vorhin gesprochen worden von 500 Domain, die der Franzose einfangen wollte. Das wären ja letztendlich höchstens mal maximal 25 Millionen Dollar. Erstens würde mich jetzt also interessieren, was noch der Grund ist, warum die Amerikaner an diesem Server dort festhalten und was es ihnen bringt, was bei ihnen steht. Und zweitens würde mich interessieren, ob es technische Möglichkeiten gibt, jetzt einen Alternativen-Server aufzubauen oder mehrere. Weil so habe ich eigentlich das Internet verstanden, dass es also ausfallssicher ist, weil ein Server ersetzt wird als ein anderer. Und wenn es diese Möglichkeit gibt, dann würde ich mir wünschen, dass die beiden Deutschen, weil sie ja echte Extrapen sind, wie ich das jetzt mitgekriegt habe, sich dafür einsetzen, dass man also quasi diese Vormachtstellung jetzt bei Icann abbaut, indem man irgendwo anders auf der Welt auch Server aufbaut, die so dieses hierarchische Modell irgendwie beseitigen. Also würde mich interessieren, ob so etwas möglich ist.
Die Rootname-Server sind ja bereits strategisch gleichmäßig über das Netz verteilt. Und natürlich könnte man jetzt beschließen, dass man in Europa, wir spalten uns jetzt mal von den USA ab, weil wir sind das Light und naja, wir richten jetzt hier unsere eigenen Rootname-Server ein, betreiben unsere Top-Level-Doment selbst, benennen sie vielleicht sogar um, weil das Geschichte mit.de ist ja einfach mal langweilig. Das könnte man natürlich alles machen.
Das Problem dabei ist...
Nein, Moment Esch, das war nicht ganz die Frage, sondern die Frage, die ihr gestellt habt, ist, was ist, wenn ich jetzt losgehe und sage, ich mache jetzt eine neue TLD auf und die nenne ich.dd, das war nämlich die TLD der DDR. Jetzt gibt es die DDR vielleicht nicht mehr als juristisches Gebiet, aber in meinem Kopf gibt es sie halt noch und deswegen will ich jetzt eine TLD, wo ich alle ehemaligen coolen Ostbetriebe irgendwie reinpacke und die Künstler sowieso. Weswegen kann ich das nicht? Das war glaube ich die Frage.
Du kannst das natürlich machen. Das Problem dabei ist, dass damit dein Server für die Domain-DD gefunden wird, er in den Rootname-Servern eingetragen sein muss. Oder in den Servern, die die Clients, die auf DD zugreifen wollen, als Rootname-Server betrachten. Diese Rootname-Server sind ja einfach nur durch eine Vereinbarung zu Rootname-Servern geworden. Im Prinzip kann man jeden beliebigen Name-Server da draußen zum Rootname-Server erklären. Das müssen halt nur Benutzer so in ihrem System eintragen, dass dieser Server als Rootname-Server verwendet wird.
Und wenn wir dann automatisiertes Update für die entsprechenden Clients raushauen würden, als Alternative zu ICANN davon überzeugen, dass sie sich mit ihrem Rootname-Server mal nicht so ansteuern sollen? Das hast du jetzt gesagt. Aber ich meine, das ist interessanterweise. Also es gibt ja jetzt zwei. Die andere Frage war ja, warum stellen die sich so an? Warum machen die das nicht einfach? Und das hat nicht nur mit Geld zu tun.
Das ist politischer Druck.
Exakt, das hat eben genau damit zu tun, dass die Amerikaner im Moment, es gibt ja für die Streitigkeiten, die es da gibt, und die gibt es ja gerade eine ganze Menge, um diese Namens, gibt es ja ein Verfahren, um diese Streit sozusagen zu lösen, zumindest für die Com, org.net und so fort. Das heißt UDRP, das ist das Universal Disput Resolution Protocol. Und das ist mehr oder weniger ein Verfahren, um eben erst mal herauszufinden, wer hier Recht hat und wer nicht Recht hat, und wie man, während man das herausfindet, verfährt. Allerdings ist die Schiedsgerichtsbarkeit, das heißt die Institution, die, wenn die Leute sich nicht einig werden, dann letztendlich die Entscheidung fällt, zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt eben die WIPO. Und die WIPO?
Vier.
Ja gut, aber die WIPO?
Ist einer.
Und die anderen drei?
Sind nicht so beschissen gestimmt wie die WIPO.
Du meinst, das sind hier die unten links? Nicht?
Es gibt inzwischen vier Schiedsgerichtsbarkampf. WIPO war die erste zugelassene. Ein paar andere sitzen noch in den USA. Aber die Kläger wenden sich am liebsten an die WIPO, weil die am freundlichsten im Umgang mit Markenzeichen-Eigentümern ist.
Ja nun, das ist ja der Verband der Markenrechtsinhaber. Insofern ist das nun nicht weiter verwunderlich. Aber um nur kurz, wir haben ja den Herrn hier noch in der Leitung, um nochmal kurz diese Frage zu beantworten. Also für mich sieht das so aus, als haben die sich da eine Regelung ausgedacht, die eben amerikanischen Vorstellungen des Umgangs mit diesem Problem entspricht. Und das heißt im Zweifelsfall Markenzeichenrecht vor zwei Umgangs.
Aber der fragt sich ja noch alternativen Routes.
Ja, das war aber die zweite Frage. Er hat zwei Fragen. Moment, Moment Tim. Und wir sind jetzt immer noch kurz beim ersten Teil. Und der erste Teil ist, letztendlich ist das amerikanische Kultur, die da weltweit exportiert wird. Wie hat man das Kulturimperialismus genannt? Also ich finde die da herrlich unbescheidend. Und letztendlich wissen die ja auch, naja Moment mal kurz, die wissen ja, dass die Beherrschung des Namensraumes letztendlich auch die Beherrschung wirtschaftlicher Vorgänge mit sich bringt.
Ja, und auch vor allen Dingen die Art, wie darüber entschieden wird. Das ist ja abgekupfert von amerikanischem Recht. Die exportieren quasi ihr eigenes Rechtssystem, ihre Rechtsauffassungen und das System, nach dem das jeweils geltend gemacht wird.
Exakt, und insofern ist es nichts weiter als das, was die Amerikaner nun in vielen anderen Bereichen, auch ohne Computer, seit langer Zeit tun, nämlich sich versuchen, diesen Beten zu ihren Gunsten unter den Nagel zu reißen. War das jetzt eine valide Antwort auf deine erste Frage? Gut, oder also eine schlüssige vor allem. Und jetzt kommen wir mal zu der zweiten Frage. Und die ist in der Tat, da können wir jetzt also zwei Strategien wählen. Die Strategie 1, und die werden wir sicherlich gesetzlichen Fall einer von uns kommt da rein, wählen ist natürlich, ICANN klar zu machen, dass die Beherrschung des Root-Name-Servers und damit die Beherrschung, wer eine TLD betreibt und wer nicht, dass das jetzt mal aufhören muss und dass das tatsächlich jeder, der eine aufmachen will, soll das auch im Prinzip tun können, wenn er dann vielleicht noch die technische Kompetenz kurz... Wollte ich vielleicht nicht gleich übertreiben. Das sind ja zwei verschiedene Aspekte. Nehmen wir jetzt aber mal an, die amerikanische Regierung ist im Moment da noch ein bisschen verspannt wegen der Antwort auf deine erste Frage und macht das also nicht. Dann brauchen wir langfristig eine andere Strategie und die könnte in der Tat auch daran bestehen, andere Root-Name-Server sozusagen in die Client-Software zur Anerkennung hineinzubringen.
Das wird irgendwann auch passieren.
Ja, ich meine, das ist doch eigentlich gar kein so großer Hack im Sinne von Ash, kannst du dazu mal was sagen? Ich meine, das kommt mir jetzt im Moment nicht wie besonders viel Arbeit vor, so ein Ding zu programmieren. Für diesen oder jenen Client, die hier jetzt gerade so vorenstehen oder für den dritten hier nicht stehenden. Das einzige Problem ist doch ein bisschen die Distribution davon, oder?
Im Endeffekt müssen ja nicht die Applikationen, die Client-Software selbst wissen, welcher Nameserver jetzt wofür zuständig ist, weil bei ordentlich strukturierten Systemen übernimmt das ja der sogenannte Resolver. Unter Unix-Suite-Systemen wird dieser konfiguriert über die bekannte ETC ResolveConf. Und es würde einfach schon völlig ausreichen, dort einen Rootnameserver einzutragen, der nicht dem normalen Rootnameservermuster entspricht. Das wäre nun eine wirklich unschöne Lösung, weil die dann alle den alternativen Rootnameserver fragen würden. Aber der andere Weg wäre, einen Caching-Only-Nameserver zu haben. Generell gibt man einen Nameserver, der als Resolver für andere Clients arbeiten soll, einen sogenannten Rootpunkt-Cache-File, in dem aufgelistet ist, wer momentan die Rootnameserver sind. Wenn man ein wirklich veraltetes Rootpunkt-Cache-File hat, fühlt es sich zu einem sehr interessanten Verhalten des Nameservers. Aber an sich könnte man dort einfach jetzt beschließen, dass wir uns unsere fünf Nameserver in die Root-Cache eintragen, die alle über die top-level-domain.ccc Bescheid wissen.
Es gab doch dieses Alternic-Projekt, was im Prinzip genau das versucht hat zu realisieren, wo man sich auch schon seine top-level-domains registrieren lassen konnte. Was ist denn aus denen geworden?
Das ist doch dieser Typ in New York, oder?
Genau, der auch eine kritische...
Das war einer von vielen. Ist der nicht sogar irgendwie eingebucht worden?
Ich glaube, so schlimm ist es nicht gewesen. Es ist überhaupt auch ein sehr aktiver Netzkünstler gewesen, der interessante Installationen gemacht hat. Ich habe das jetzt auch nicht weiter verfolgt, aber im Prinzip haben die das genau gemacht. Sie hatten letztlich auch technische Probleme. Ich habe es mal probiert, einfach mal über die laufen zu lassen. Das hat dann eben nicht so richtig gut funktioniert, aber im Prinzip bedürfte es sozusagen nur eines Agreements. Das bedürfte eigentlich ohnehin einer Sache, die sie jetzt sowieso machen müssen, weil seitdem Kopen ja auch von mehreren übernommen wird. Es ist also ohnehin ja eine Aufteilung im Sinne des kapitalistischen Systems gibt zwischen verschiedenen Entitäten, die sich sozusagen um Domänauskünfte bemühen. Da könnte man eben genauso auch für beliebig viele weitere Top-Level-Domäns mit reinnehmen.
Nur der Wille dazu, der existiert eben nicht. Ja, aber könnte man das nicht auch auf Ebene eines ISPs machen, dass man die ISPs dazu bringt, dass sie ihre DNS wiederum mit Verwaltungsfunktionen, was du eben gerade sagtest, würde das nicht ausreichen, wenn die mitspielen? Weil dann würden die ISPs, die das tun, ja ihren Kunden mehr bieten als andere. Das wäre doch eine coole Erweiterung, oder nicht?
Natürlich ist das grundsätzlich möglich. Wo innerhalb der DNS-Hierarchie ich diesen alternativen Routenameserver ansetze, wo ich den ins Spiel bringe, wo ich den eintrage, das kann natürlich einfach auf Ebene des einzelnen Users sein, der jetzt in seiner Firma sitzt und einen anderen Nameserver benutzt als der Rest der Firma. Das kann natürlich auf Ebene der Firmenadministration erfolgen. Ich kenne viele Firmen, die intern Warte-DNS-Routes zones fahren, wie Punkt Local, einfach nur damit sie intern andere Hostnamen verwenden können als draußen. Und um da auch eine Trennung zu haben, dass die innere Struktur nicht von außen sichtbar ist. Aber das kann man natürlich auch auf Ebene eines ISPs machen.
Das Problem ist halt nur, ob die anderen bereit sind, darauf zuzugreifen. Das heißt, ob die, die sich darunter registrieren lassen, überhaupt sichtbar sind weltweit oder nicht. Das hängt sehr davon ab, wie die anderen darauf reagieren.
Ich habe gerade mal nachgeguckt. Ihr könnt mal schauen unter www.alternic.org. Da ist sozusagen genau so etwas, wovon wir gerade gesprochen haben. Die haben dann auch ein alternatives Rootcache-File, also eine andere Basis-Informationsdatei, die euren Nameservern sagt, wo überhaupt geguckt werden soll. Die Einträgt hat man sozusagen auch die ganzen Top-Level-Domains, die bei Alternic schon registriert sind. Nun ist Alternic halt nicht akzeptiert von den anderen. Eine URL, die man rausgibt, die eine dieser Top-Level-Domains enthält, wird natürlich woanders im Netz nicht entsprechend aufgelöst. Aber das zeigt zumindest, dass es technisch überhaupt gar keinen Problem ist, es geht mit der heutigen Struktur.
Da würde es dann irgendjemanden wehtun als ISP, wenn er jetzt zum Beispiel Alternic standardmäßig eintragen würde. Doch eigentlich nicht. Oder gibt es einen RFC, der einem das verbietet?
Nö, eigentlich nicht. Du kannst machen, was du willst.
Grundsätzlich gibt es natürlich erstmal keinen Verbot, alternative Top-Level-Domains oder was auch immer zu unterstützen. Die Frage ist dann halt irgendwo, inwieweit man noch zum Rest dieses Netzes kompatibel ist. Weil der große Vorteil dieses Netzes ist, dass man sich auf bestimmte Dinge geeinigt hat. Ich bin nicht dabei, ein schlechtes Gefühl URLs zu verteilen, die sozusagen nur innerhalb meiner Gruppe gültig sind.
Aber das Wesentliche ist doch, finde ich, was man daraus lernen kann, ist, dass es mit der Architektur des Netzes nicht anders ist, als mit anderen gesellschaftlichen Institutionen auch. Regeln gelten immer nur solange, wie sich die Mehrzahl daran hält. Und wenn jemand anfängt, etwas Neues zu machen und die verändert und die anderen ziehen mit, dann geht auch das. Es gibt keinen technischen Hinderungsgrund in dem Bereich.
Einen technischen Hinderungsgrund eher nicht?
Sebastian?
Ja, hallo, wollte nur eine kleine Ergänzung zu dem ICANN 50.000 Dollar. Ich will eine TLD haben.
Das ist nur das Antragsverfahren und das kriegt man auch nicht zurück, wenn man abgelehnt wird.
Das ist der Skandal.
Stimmt, völlig richtig.
Also es ist eigentlich nur eine, gib uns mal eine Runde Geld.
Ja, non-refundable, womit man ausschließt, dass bestimmte Leute, entweder die, die kein Geld haben oder die einem sonst nicht passen, überhaupt Anträge einreichen.
Das war's schon.
Danke Sebastian.
Hallo Heiko.
Ja, du bist dran.
Ja, und zwar hab ich eigentlich eine Frage, eine technisch politische Frage. Wenn man jetzt tatsächlich alternative Rootname Server einführt, dann weiß ich nicht, inwieweit tatsächlich sich das Netz dadurch spaltet. Und ich glaube, das wäre das Schlimmste, was passieren könnte, dass das Internet sich spaltet, dass bestimmte Leute bestimmte Inhalte nicht mehr erreichen können. Und ich glaube, da sollte man also alles daran setzen, sich irgendwie mit Icann und noch immer zu einigen, dass wirklich von jedem Punkt, egal wo ich auf dieser Welt bin, ich wirklich jede Webseite erreichen kann.
Na, diese Befürchtung hatte ich ja gerade schon geäußert, aber das Ziel solcher zusätzlichen Top-Label-Domains kann natürlich auch einfach sein, eine geschlossene Benutzergruppe zu bilden. Das wird im Allgemeinen, also bei den momentan mir bekannten zusätzlichen Top-Label-Domains, ist das der Fall, dass da halt sich zum Beispiel Administratoren hingesetzt haben und beschlossen haben, dass sie jetzt eine Punkt-BOFH Hierarchie bilden möchten.
Also ich sehe das Problem einfach darin, dass es wirklich dann Bereiche gibt. Man kann von bestimmten Betreibern, also man sieht das jetzt ja schon, dass innerhalb von bestimmten Betreibergruppen bei bestimmten Internet-Providern halt eigene Netzangebote entstehen, die von anderen nicht mehr zu erreichen sind. Und das wird einfach weiter fortschreiten. Microsoft bietet eigene Channels an, AOL immerhin der große Internet-Providerdienst gibt, hat eigene Inhalte und...
Ja Moment, aber das sind Online-Dienste. Das ist schon ein klein bisschen was anderes, weil AOL und die Online, das sind ja sozusagen Dienste, erstmal lokale, kannst du dir vorstellen wie Mailboxen, die dir erstmal Lokalkontent geben und dann haben sie halt auch Internet. Insofern ist das nicht vergleichbar.
Ich glaube, diesen Unterschied kann man nicht machen. Weil es geht eigentlich nur darum, dass die Welt online wird, dass die Leute online sind und online irgendetwas machen. Und wenn davon andere Leute wieder ausgeschlossen werden, ist das das größte Problem. Und der Erfolg des Internets gründet sich nur darauf, dass eigentlich alles gleich war.
Ja, das ist schon richtig, aber AOL ist streng genommen nicht das Internet, sondern es ist eben ein Online-Dienst. Es ist so wie es früher eben Mailboxen gab und es gab vernetzte Mailboxen.
Sekunde, Entschuldigung, Heiko hast du zwei Minuten Zeit? Wir machen eben Nachrichten, bleib dran. Null Uhr 31. Ja, mit dem Wetter natürlich. Wenn nachts zieht der Regen ab, es kann örtlich zu Nebelbildung kommen. Temperaturen um 9 Grad tagsüber wechselnd bewölkt, meist trocken bei 17 bis 20 Grad. Und die Meldung mit Gerhard Tritt-Americh.
In Berlin droht heute ein Verkehrschaos. Tausende Trucker und Taxifahrer aus ganz Deutschland wollen mit einer Sternfahrt gegen die Ökosteuer und die hohen Spritpreise protestieren. Die Polizei empfiehlt Berufspendler mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln zu fahren. Die Berliner Verkehrsbetriebe und die S-Bahn bieten verbildigte Tipps. Nach den Grünen hat auch die Bundestagsfraktion der SPD die Rentenreformpläne von Arbeitsminister Riester gebilligt. Riester kündigte an, er werde noch in dieser Woche Union und FDP zu einer neuen Konsensrunde einladen. Der israelische Ministerpräsident Barak und der palästinensische Präsident Arafat sind am späten Abend zusammengekommen. Beide wollten versuchen, den stockenden Friedensprozess wieder in Gang zu bringen. Das Treffen fand in Baraks Privatbarake statt. Das Ergebnis der Präsidentschaftswahlen in Jugoslawien soll heute bekannt gegeben werden. Vorab gaben sich sowohl das Lager um Präsident Milošević, als auch die Opposition um den Kandidaten Kostunica und Sieg ist gewiss. An Bord einer Sondermaschine im Fußball Champions League Sieger Real Madrid hat es gestern eine Panik gegeben. Auf dem Flug nach Düsseldorf hatte die Boeing wegen eines Druck von einer Minute 5000 Meter an Höhe verloren. Alle Hinsassen, darunter auch Fans und Pressevertreter, kamen mit dem Schrecken davon.
Vielen Dank, Gerald Kötter-Heinrich.
You're listening to Night Flight with Jens. Mit weit über 40 Millionen im verkauften Platten ist er mit Sicherheit einer der erfolgreichsten Künstler der Sparte Rock. David Caradale, Xtie Purple, Leadsinger und Kopf von Whitesnake ist zurück und zu Gast im heutigen großen Night Flight Interview Special. Into the Light heißt sein neuer Longplayer, den ihr selbstverständlich auch gewinnen könnt. Außerdem Musik von The Fall, Elastica, Division, aber auch von Fonehm, Alles wie groß und Hans Nieswand. Ich gehe mal davon aus, wir hören uns.
Night Flight ab eins mit und an der Sprechgarnitur.
Station, die aufhört.
Hahaha!
Das Chaosradio 54, wir reden über Namen und Nummernvergabe im Internet und Heiko ist immer noch am Telefon, hoffe ich zumindest.
Ja, das bin ich.
Ja, das ist doch klasse, Heiko.
Wo waren wir stehengeblieben?
Ja, wir waren eigentlich da stehengeblieben, dass das Internet sich immer weiter spaltet. Und ich meine das eigentlich auch dahingehend, dass diese kommerzielle Spaltung schon stattfindet.
Eigentlich kann wir im Moment keine kommerzielle Spaltung, sondern ein Zusammenwachsen der eigentlich gespaltenen Netze, weil wenn wir davon ausgegangen sind, was wir vor 15 Jahren hatten, dann waren das getrennte Benutzer mit ihren eigenen Netzen, wie AOL, BTX, Prodigy, CompuServe, gab eine ganze Menge davon. Und die haben nach und nach überhaupt erst dieses seltsame komische Netz, dieses nicht Kapitalistische mit IPv4, mal in ihr Angebot aufgenommen, als sie von ihren Kunden darum gebeten wurden. Aber AOL ist eigentlich immer noch ein Online-Dienst, der eigenen Content anbietet. Und das mit dem Internet ist inzwischen eigentlich nur so dazugekommen.
Ich befürchte nur, dass jetzt also, nachdem halt die kommerziellen Erwägungen mit den Nutzergruppen einzuführen, bzw. nur bestimmte Leute mit Angebot zu lassen, jetzt auch die Leute, die quasi nicht kommerziell sind, anfangen sich zu streiten und auch viele Leute ausschließen unter bestimmten Sachen. Ich erwarte nur auf den Tag, dass ich irgendwie eine Homepage auf irgendeinem Top-Level-Domain hier von Deutschland aus anzuwerfen kann. Und heute in Amerika kann das nicht.
Ja gut, das Problem ist halt in der Tat, dass entweder greift das Icann jetzt halt auf den Drang nach mehr Diversifizierung, also dass es eben mehr TLDs gibt, und dann wird das in einer geordneten Art und Weise veranstaltet. Oder aber die weigern sich eben weiterhin. Und dann wird es wahrscheinlich erst mal eine Zeit ziemlich chaotisch, bis dann eben eine alternative Instanz entsteht, die das ordentlich wiederum macht. So und deswegen unternehmen wir ja hier auch den Versuch, jetzt erstmal Icann dazu zu bringen, diese erwahrungsgemäße Zahlen durchzuführen, weil wir auch nicht unbedingt, auch wenn wir der Chaos Computer Club hier mitunter sind, jetzt das völlige, reine und unichlichliche Orientierung ausgestattete Chaos bevorzugen. Insofern, Herrgott, wir werden das sicherlich probieren, aber trotzdem muss man sich ja auch mal die Frage stellen, was ist denn eigentlich, wenn die Amerikaner eben so weiterhin drauf sitzen bleiben und das einfach nicht machen. Weil so geht es ja nicht weiter, das ist ja auch das Problem. Also ansonsten kannst du irgendwie dir eine beliebige Domain registrieren und auf den Tag warten, bis irgendein Schrieb von irgendeinem Anwalt kommt, der dir sagt, dass dieser Domainname gerade in Unterägypten als Warnzeichen registriert wurde und dass die da gerade mal all deine Erspartes wegnehmen müssen.
Also man kann es ja auch so formulieren, der bisherige Scham und auch die Robustheit des Nazis kam ja gerade dadurch zustande, dass so viel wie möglich delegiert wurde. Und zentrale Autorität nur in den Bereichen bestand, die wirklich absolut zentral reguliert werden müssen. Nun sind wir inzwischen dahinter gekommen, das Domainnahmesystem gehört eventuell gar nicht zu diesen Bereichen. Es ist technisch durchaus möglich, Aufgaben, die bislang zentral wahrgenommen werden, die auch verteilt zur Hand haben. Und wenn das denn technisch möglich ist, muss man sich in der Tat fragen, ob ICANN seine relativ restriktive Politik, was die Einrichtung neuer Top-Level-Domains anbelangt, soweit betreiben können darf oder ob man da andere technisch mögliche, verteiltere Entscheidungs- und Verantwortungsstrukturen einführen kann.
Über was von Zeit rum reden wir da?
Die nächsten drei Jahre.
Heiko, geht es dir gut?
Noch Fragen?
Nein, eigentlich ein Prinzipchen C.
Alles klar, danke für deinen Anruf. Falls ihr noch hier anrufen wollt, 20 Minuten sind wir noch da. Hier ist die Nummer.
0331, Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Wir reden über Namen und Nummern, Vergabe im Internet. Das ist nämlich das Chaosradio hier. Und Jeanette hat sich ein Lied gewünscht. Was hören wir jetzt?
Ein Sommerhit. Jetzt hören wir ein Stück, das heißt Up with the People, ursprünglich von Lamp Shop. Und wir hören die Version von Zero7.
Nein, eine Radio-Sendung.
Ja, abgefahren. Was war das, was wir da gehört haben?
Schon der Name ist absolut programmatisch. Ein Stück von Lamb Chop in der Remix-Version von 07, zwei britischen Remixern, die es wirklich in sich haben. Alles, was die machen, ist einfach wunderbar.
Gehört im Chaosradio hier auf Fritz, Chaosradio 54, die ganze Zeit reden wir über Icann und so weiter. Gibt es sonst noch irgendwie was Neues zu vermelden eigentlich? Mal davon abgesehen, dass es in Friedrichshain kein DSL gibt.
Willst du schnell das Internet haben?
Friedrichshain war, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, eins der sogenannten Opal-Ghetto, einfach konzeptbedingt nicht möglich ist. Warum? Da ist mal ein Telekommunikationsanbieter auf die grandiose Idee gekommen, dass Glasfaser die Zukunft darstellt, hat in jedes Haus unten zwei Doppelader Glasfaser reingelegt, hat dann schicke Endbenutzer-Module dran geschaltet, mit denen man dann so normale ISDN-Anschlüsse mit Kupfer daraus macht aus den Glasfasern. Aber DSL ist immer eine Technologie, die erfordert, dass da ein bis zwei Doppeladern Kupfer vom Benutzer bis zur Vermittlungsstelle liegen. Und da liegen mal exakt gar keine. Und dazu kommt, dass bei dieser Opal-Technologie die Module inzwischen nicht mehr verfügbar sind. Das heißt, es soll schon vorgekommen sein, dass man einen zweiten ISDN-Anschluss beantragt hat, einen ganz normalen ISDN-Anschluss und die Telekom diesen Auftrag abgelehnt hat. Und von zwei Mbit-Nets vorerst nicht wirklich brechen.
Aha, und was mache ich jetzt?
Im Zweifelsfall machst du Folgendes.
Was ist hier drum?
Nein, nicht schon wieder.
Das ist doch ganz einfach Holger, was du machst, sind dicke Backen mit Berliner Luft.
Das geht so.
Das geht ja nicht nur mir so, das geht ja offensichtlich dem gesamten Friedrichshain so.
Ja, dann müssen sich die Punker eventuell mal Wavelan irgendwie aufs Dach stellen. Hatten wir dazu nicht schon eine Radioseine?
Ja, dazu hatten wir schon eine Radioseine.
Da wäre dann noch die Frage, wann kriege ich das denn? Also Frank, von dir bei mir um die Ecke, vielleicht hat er jetzt irgendwie was?
Ja, musst du dir kaufen, Wavelan-Antenne, einen Kost zu 1-200, und Wavelan-EE8.
Oder habe ich jetzt ein E vergessen? Sehr gut, da kann man nur noch mal drauf verweisen, dass man eben auch irgendwie seine eigenen Netze aufbauen kann, wenn die Telekommunikationsprovider nicht in der Lage sind, einen anzuschließen. Also Friedrichshain ist halt wirklich gerade extrem unterversorgt, und das ist schon ein bisschen bitter.
Das ist sehr peinlich, zumal die mir permanent Werbung schicken. Ich möge mir doch jetzt DSL holen.
Das ist ein kulturelles Engagement der Telekom, die wollen halt, dass der Underground noch irgendwie lange leiten bleibt.
Wir reden über ICANN.
Aber abgesehen davon gibt es ja auch noch andere Dinge.
Bei DSL gibt es ja auch das Problem, dass du keine dynamischen IP-Adressen kriegst, sondern immer nur dynamische, sprich immer nur welche, die während einer Bindung gültig sind. Und damit kannst du halt auch keinen Server aufstellen. Und damit hat sich das mit der Fretrate auch wieder so ein bisschen auf Sauger-Modell reduziert. Das was die Telekom mir heute dieser Herr Schühler interessanterweise erzählt hat, ist, dass die Kalkulationen eben wie die betriebswirtschaftlich gehen, die davon aus, dass das normale PC-Clicker sind, die halt drei Stunden pro Tag klicken. Und nachdem sie jetzt die ersten Kunden haben und verstehen, dass das nicht hinhaut, naja, die Online ist ja sowieso gerade irgendwie in großen, äußerten und finanziellen Schwierigkeiten, um es mal vorsichtig anzudeuten.
Das ist jetzt ein Anlage-Tipp?
Das ist jetzt ein Anlage-Tipp.
Herr Schiller ist übrigens auch Kandidat.
Und die eigentliche Wahl, wen es noch interessiert, die findet ja im Oktober statt, also vom 1. bis 10. Oktober, findet nach einem bislang nicht geklärten Wahlverfahren. So kann man das glaube ich korrekt einfach jetzt im Moment nur behaupten, weil da steht immer nur Jahr an der Discussion.
Es gab da heute übrigens noch was auf dem Heiseticker, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon zu Kindes genommen habt.
Wir sind ja die ganze Zeit am Wahlkämpfen, wir kommen ja nicht mehr zum Lesen.
Ihr tingelt rum und sagt, hat das hier mal einen Blühenlandschaften zu tun?
Ich hole das gerade mal auf den Schirm, on screen.
Ja, mach das mal.
Globalisierung stellt bei Waffung. Aber das ist wohl noch was anderes.
Was sagt denn der Heiseticker?
Das will Tim gerade auf den Bildschirm holen, aber der Bildschirm ist leider in einem Windows-Computer angeschlossen.
Lest mal durch, wir können es gleich zusammenfassen.
ICANN wählt Online-Wahl-Provider. Auf election.com wird es rückgegriffen. Der Online-Wahl-Provider aus den USA hat erst kürzlich Elgor die ersten Online-Stimmen bei Vorwahlen im Rahmen der Nominierung des demokratischen Präsidentschaftskandidaten eingebracht.
Das betrifft nicht das Wahlprozedere, sondern nur die Firma, die es macht.
Der Heise-Ticker ist übrigens noch ein Tipp, wenn man sich über diese ICANN-Sache mal auch, was die Ereignisse in den letzten Monaten abgelaufen sind, umfassend informieren will. Es gibt auf heise.de ein spezielles ICANN-Special, wo die ganzen Nachrichten zu dem Thema zusammengefasst sind, wo diverse Links auf diverse Informations-Webseiten zu finden sind, Hinweise auf Interviews, Chat-Transkripte, die gelaufen sind, mit den Kandidaten und anderen Sachen. Also dort werden sie geholfen.
Du hast mal gesagt.
Du hast bald gesagt.
Ansonsten, wenn du nach Neuigkeiten fragst.
Ich hätte noch eine Frage zu ICANN. Jetzt wird er gewählt, jetzt werden die Direktoren gewählt. Wie lange bleiben die da auf dem Posten?
Zwei Jahre.
Wenn die anderen alle drei Jahre drauf sind, muss man auch mal dazu sagen. Die eigentliche Wahlperiode ist länger, aber da wir ja sozusagen der Testfall sind, und niemand richtig weiß, ob er uns behalten will, ICANN hat ja auch schon angekündigt, dass sie unmittelbar nach der Wahl eine Studie vergeben werden, die das sozusagen nochmal alles aufräumen soll.
Aber dafür haben sie Geld, ja?
Nee, das ist ja das Tolle, da haben sie von Geld erst mal nicht geredet. Und deswegen hat sich zum Beispiel die Bertelsmann Stiftung, die ja gerade das Internet filtern will, um irgendwie das Ganze in einen klinischen Verkaufsraum zu verwandeln. Und die Bertelsmann Stiftung hat gesagt, nein, ihr müsst das überhaupt nicht bezahlen, weil wir haben ja Geld und wir würden euch gerne diese Studie machen.
Da reißen sich alle drum.
Man sollte sich da noch merken, dass Bertelsmann ja AOL käuflich erworben hat und damit jetzt über eine relativ große Plattform verfügt, um einer wirklich großen Menge Benutzer ihre Inhalte aufzuzwängen.
Das klingt mir irgendwie wie eine Zars. Warum macht ihr da überhaupt mit?
Wer wir?
Das klingt irgendwie so wie eine große Verarsche.
Der Witz ist doch der, dass wenn jetzt einfach nur diese Wahlen laufen würden und wir hier nicht kandidieren würden, dann würden noch weniger Leute darüber reden. Ich sehe das als eine Chance, durch die Prozedur selbst die Dinge ein bisschen mal mit der großen Lampe anzuspielen.
Ja, und es geht ja schon um wichtige Dinge, also die zentralen Ressourcen des Netzes.
Die von Bertelsmann unter anderem dann bezahlt werden. Oder die in Verwaltung unter anderem von Bertelsmann bezahlt wird.
Das ist noch ein ganz anderes Thema, dass z.B. die vornominierten Kandidaten, da gibt es gewisse Überschneidungen mit Sponsoren vergangener ICANN-Sitzungen. Das sind auch so einige der Dinge, die man am Rande bemerken könnte. Also klar, das ist im Moment die große Scheiße, die da abläuft. Bloß nützt es ja nichts, das einfach nur zu beklagen. Entweder man versucht, das zu ändern, das ist halt der Versuch. Oder man sieht, wie...
Da sind handfeste Verteilungskonflikte um Namen und künftig vermutlich auch um Nummern. Und da drauf Einfluss zu nehmen, ist doch irgendwie rechtschärfer als...
Natürlich ist es das. Aber irgendwie klingt das so ein bisschen so, als hätte das wenig Sinn. Das wäre so eine sehr vorgeweidige Aktion, die relativ wandlungsunterhinten ist.
Das würde ich nicht sagen. Was halt im Moment das Hauptproblem einer ganzen Geschichte ist, ich meine, dass Bertelsmann zum Beispiel in so einer Art und Weise da agiert. Das ist halt, Entschuldigung, normal. Ich meine, das ist halt ein faschistoides Medienunternehmen mit Absolutheitsanspruch. Das sind sie aber nicht erst seit gestern. Das Problem ist, dass das, was sie in Bezug auf ICANN zum Beispiel da versuchen zu tun, dass das im Moment in einem relativ abgeschotteten Raum passiert, von dem die wenigsten es überhaupt mitbekommen. Und ich glaube, dass man Probleme schon lösen kann, wenn man sie erstmal in der ganzen Bandbreite wahrnimmt. Und insofern muss es hier darum gehen, erstmal das Problem in der ganzen Bandbreite erfassbar zu machen, um es dann eben anzugehen. Und wenn die Lösung dann nachher lautet, ICANN auflösen, andere Rootname-Server und mehr TLDs, Herrgott, dann ist es das. Aber im Moment ist es halt so, dass gerade viele Medienunternehmen, ich meine, den Spiegel kann man jetzt sagen, hat da toll drüber berichtet. Aber über die vielen Details, die da eigentlich so verkehrt laufen, hat Spiegel noch ziemlich wenig berichtet und andere noch viel weniger, weil das halt zugegebenerweise auch ein bisschen hinter irgendwelchen Fachterminen versteckt wird.
Und wenn die zwei Jahre um sind, wird dann neu gewählt, oder kann es dann passieren, dass sie sagen, ne, das ist ein neuer Schalt, das haben wir nie wieder.
Das hängt auch von dem Ausgang dieser Studie ab, da wo wir eben schon mal waren. ICANN hat nur gesagt, es vergebt diese Studie und hat beschlossen, was da alles geklärt werden soll, eben der Sinn und Unsinn dieser At-Large-Membership und ob man solche Direktoren überhaupt haben soll, und ob sie denn unbedingt gewählt werden müssen, ob nicht auch dritte Organisationen, die bestimmen könnten. Also wirklich grundlegende Fragen sollen da geklärt werden. Aber ICANN hat selber nichts darüber gesagt, wer sie machen soll und nach welchen Kriterien sie überhaupt erstellt werden soll. Weshalb im Moment allerlei Organisationen weltweit irgendwie in den Startblöcken sitzen. Und daran teilnehmen wollen.
Und unbedingt diese Studie finanzieren wollen.
Ja, bis sie auch machen wollen.
Hm, Tim, ich sollte dich noch fragen, ob es irgendwelche Neuigkeiten gibt.
Es gibt noch irgendwelche Neuigkeiten, Jungs. Und wir haben auch noch ganz andere Teams und deswegen veranstalten wir Ende des Jahres nämlich einen Kongress.
Genau, wie wir das jedes Jahr tun, tun wir das auch in diesem Jahr. Der mittlerweile 17. Chaos Communication Kongress wird zu seinem traditionellen Termin. Das ist der 27. bis 29. Dezember 2000 stattfinden. Das sind die drei Tage zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr. Und dort wird wieder eine ganze Menge passieren. Es findet auch wieder da statt, wo es die letzten beiden Jahre stattgefunden hat, im Haus am Kölnischen Park in Berlin-Mitte. Und wir erwarten wieder viele illustre Gäste und werden uns bemühen, ein möglichst abwechslungsreiches und interessantes und anspruchsvolles Kontrollprogramm zusammenzustellen.
Kannst du mal aufhören mit den formalisierten Sätzen?
Wir machen einen geilen Kongress und es wird ziemlich entspannt machen. Wir haben eine Menge lustige Ideen.
Ich glaube, wir gehen jetzt hier schlafen und wenn ihr mehr Infos haben wollt, dann geht ihr einfach auf www.hk.tv.
Die Informationen im Web gibt es noch nicht. Die werden allerdings in den nächsten drei Wochen geliefert werden. Das befindet sich alles in heftiger Vorbereitung.
Der Flyer-Entwurf ist wirklich sehr geil. Der Flyer wird geil.
Das ist aber noch geheim.
Ich sage auch nicht, dass der aussieht wie...
Nein, das ist auch geheim.
Das war Chaosradio 54 für heute. Chaosradio 55 wird ein Jubiläum sein. Wie geartet das auch immer? Wie sich das gestalten wird?
500 Jahre Chaosradio. Genau genommen sind es nur fünf. Wir haben dann irgendwas voll. Das ist Chaosradio 55. Fünf Jahre Chaosradio. Wir haben uns etwas ausgedacht. Das ist allerdings auch noch geheim. Wir hoffen, dass ihr alle zuschaltet. Per Satellit, per UKW, per MP3, per ReaAudio, wenn es sein muss. Oder wie auch immer. Und jetzt haben wir keine Lust mehr.
Jetzt gehen wir nach Hause. Vielen Dank, dass ihr hier wart. Danke Janett, Andi, Janett und Andi. Viel Glück, viel Erfolg. Wenigstens einem von euch beiden dabei. Auf dass ihr dann vielleicht im Spiegel auch mal die Fahres entlarvt. Chaosradio 54 verabschiedet sich.
Einen habe ich noch. Nur weil ich es schon lange nicht mehr erwähnt habe. Es gibt für Chaosradio eine Mailingliste, also einen Ankündigungsverteiler genauer gesagt. chaosradio-ticker schickt eine Mail an chaosradio-ticker-subscribe-at-lists.ccc.de und dann kriegt ihr immer Ankündigungen vor der Sendung, mal pünktlich, mal nicht ganz so pünktlich. Dann seid ihr dabei und drin.
Genau, und ansonsten wer noch Fragen hat, chaosradio-at-fritz.de. Ich leite das dann an die entsprechenden Leute weiter. Tschüss.
Na, jetzt bleiben wir zu sehen. Na, jetzt bleiben wir zu sehen. Na, jetzt bleiben wir zu sehen. Na, jetzt bleiben wir zu sehen. Na, jetzt bleiben wir zu sehen. Schönen Morgen! Wenn ihr die letzten drei Stunden Bahnhof verstanden habt, wird ihr mit den Insel-Affage-Quatscher heute auch noch mehr Bahnhof verstehen. Das alles bis 4 Uhr morgens. Guten Morgen! Ich bin immer noch da.